I WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO THE
JOINT HEARING. OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE SET
UP TO DATE WE HAVE. A VERY
FRUITFUL AND TIMELY DISCUSSION
ABOUT AUTOMATION.
I EN THERE IS BEEN MUCH
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE BENEFITS
AND POSSIBLE.
NATIVE ISSUES AS WELL TODAY WE
HOPE TO HAVE A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT.
OUR MODEL NATION OBVIOUSLY CAN
BRING BENEFITS.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO ARE
CONCERNED. ABOUT DISPLACEMENT OF
JOBS AND WE THINK THAT THE
CONVERSATION SHOULD BE ABOUT HOW
WE WORK TOGETHER ACROSS SECTORS.
OUGHT TO USE THOSE TECHNOLOGY
BENEFITS.
BUT NOT IN A WAY THAT IS NEARLY
ABOUT REPLACING OF THE WORK
FORCE AND SO WE HOPE TO HAVE A
ROBUST DISCUSSION. UPON THOSE
MATTERS TODAY AND WE WELCOME
PARTICIPATION FROM ALL OF YOU.
OUT WILL HEAR FROM OF VARIOUS
MEMBERS OF BOTH SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY LABOR COMMITTEES AS
THEY ARE COMING IN AND OUT
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. NOW WE'VE
GOT GREAT PANELS FOR YOU FROM
SEVERAL SECTORS POSSIBLE GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED ON A ONE
ACKNOWLEDGE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SIMULATOR COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. AND I INVITE HIM
IF HE WISHES TO MAKE A FEW
OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU A CHAIR THURMOND FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
AS CHAIR THEY WERE COMMITTEE
BUT ALSO ON THIS ISSUE I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO EVERYONE THAT'S HERE
TO BE PART OF THIS CONVERSATION
THAT REALLY.
IS LONG OVERDUE.
BUT IS CERTAINLY NOT SIMPLE AND
IT'S GONNA BE A AN ISSUE I THINK
THAT ESPECIALLY BEING FROM
SILICON VALLEY.
BUT ANYWHERE IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE NATION
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH THE
YEARS AHEAD OF WHERE. I WE HAVE
A GREAT OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
PRESENTED TO US PUBLIC
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENTS IN
TECHNOLOGY.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO FIND
WAYS TO ALLOW THOSE ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY. A TO BOOST OUR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORK.
AND AND QUALITY JOBS AND I
THINK I THINK BOTH CAN BE DONE
AND I THINK THEY THEY CAN BOTH
BE DONE ONLY F. WERE ENGAGING.
IN THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS AND
I APPRECIATE OUR CHAIR OF OF FOR
BRINGING US TOGETHER TO HAVE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
THE MEMBER KALRA UP WE LIKE TO
CALL OUR FIRST PANEL.
WHICH WILL BE FOCUSED ON THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE LANDSCAPE OF
WORKING CALIFORNIA.
WOULD PLEASE TO HAVE DAVID
WHILE WHO IS THE DEAN OF THE
HELLER SCHOOL FOR SOCIAL POLICY.
AND DR ANNETTE BERNHARDT AT THE
UC BERKELEY LAW LABOR CENTER
IN MY DISTRICT WHERE PLEASE
ADHERE.
.
WE DO THINGS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY ON THE ASSEMBLY.
LABOR COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT
THEY. PROBABLY ASK YOU TO TALK
LONGER WE OFTEN ASK OUR
PANELISTS JUST TO GIVE US THE
HIGHLIGHTS GIVE IT SAYS TEN TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES WE OFTEN ASKS
THAT CONSIDER THAT. TO THREE AND
GIVE US THE HIGHLIGHTS SO THAT.
I'M CODE SWITCHING YOU KNOW
THAT'S ASSEMBLY LABOR SPEAK FOR
IT GIVE US THE HIGHLIGHTS SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THE MAJORITY
THE TIME FOR QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION. PALM BUT WE
OBVIOUSLY WILL MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE PLENTY OF TIME TO GET
ACROSS WHATEVER YOU NEED TO
KNOW.
THAT SAID WELCOME AYE WE WELCOME
WE'RE READY FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THAT IS QUITE A CHALLENGE FOR AN
ACADEMIC OUT TO DO IT IN TWO
MINUTES.
.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND THE INVITATION FROM THE
CHAIR AND AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE.
.
I I'M I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT.
THE ISSUE OF AUTOMATION IN THE
CONTEXT OF SOME LARGER CHANGES
THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ON IN IN
THE WORKPLACE.
THAT I THINK HAVE FUNDAMENTALLY
ALREADY AFFECTED WORKING PEOPLE.
AND I I COME TO THIS DISCUSSION
WITH THE HAPPY BACKGROUND. MAY
BE UNUSUAL BACKGROUND WHILE I
HAVE BEEN AN ACADEMIC FOR MOST
MY CAREER AND RECENTLY BECAME
DEAN AT. BRANDEIS.
I HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AS THE
HEAD OF THE WAGE AND HOUR
DIVISION.
AT THE LABOR DEPARTMENT WHERE I
SAW MANY OF THESE CHANGES FIRST
HAND. AS WE DID IN FORCE MEANT
OF THE MINIMUM WAGE OVER TIME
AND OUR OTHER BASIC LABOR
STANDARDS OF FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN TILL THE END OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE COMMENTS I WANNA MAKE
ARE BASED BOTH ON RESEARCH THAT
I'VE DONE THAT OTHER PEOPLE
INCLUDING.
AND THAT A BURN HARD AND OTHERS
HAVE DONE ON CHANGES IN THE
WORKPLACE BUT ALSO DO REFLECT.
WHAT WE FOUND VERY CLEARLY
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT PATTERNS OF CHANGES IN THE
STRUCTURE OF WORK AND THEIR
IMPLICATIONS ON WORKING PEOPLE
ON THE VIOLATION? OF MANY OF OUR
MOST BASIC LABOR STANDARDS.
THE MAIN POINTS I'D MAKE AND
AND MAYBE IF I COULD TAKE MY
TIME TO MAKE MY MAIN POINTS AND
THEN GIVE ONE ILLUSTRATION THAT
I THINK SPEAKS TO. THE
TRANSFORMATION IS.
MANY OF US IN ACADEMICS HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN HAD TENDED.
FUTURE OF WORK CONVENING SO
OVER THE LAST A NUMBER OF YEARS
OFTEN FOCUSED ON THE ISSUES OF
AUTOMATION IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN THEIR IMPACTS.
ON LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT.
.
WELL THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY WILL BE THE
SUBJECT OF A LOT OF TODAY'S
DISCUSSION. I WOULD ALSO MAKE
THE POINT THAT THE FUTURE OF
WORK IS ALREADY HERE AND THERE
HAS ALREADY BEEN A PROFOUND
TRANSFORMATION IN.
THE EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIP THAT
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR PROBABLY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS BUT
ACCELERATED AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION. AND.
I'VE TURNED THIS CHANGE THE
FEATURED WORKPLACE IN THE
FEATURED WORKPLACE.
IT IS REALLY.
BUSINESSES REORGANIZING.
.
FOCUSING ON ONE HAND MORE AND
MORE ON CORE COMPETENCIES AND BY
CORE COMPETENCIES I MEAN THINGS
LIKE BRANDING THEIR PRODUCTS.
BRINGING NEW PRODUCTS TO MARKET
DOING THINGS LIKE LOOK
DELIVERING OUR PACKAGES TO OUR
HOME.
AT THE SAME TIME AS THEY'VE BEEN
DOING THAT THEY HAVE ALSO BEEN.
VERY.
INCREASINGLY SHIFTING WORK OUT
OF THEIR OWN EMPLOYMENT
SUBCONTRACTING WORK FRANCHISING
WORK USING THIRD PARTY
CONTRACTORS. TO AN EXTENT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T OFTEN PERCEIVED.
JUST HOW MANY PEOPLE WHO WE
THINK ARE AMAZON EMPLOYEES WHO
WE THINK ARE EMPLOYEES OF. A
COMPANIES LIKE APPLE WHO ARE NO
LONGER ACTUALLY THOSE DIRECT
EMPLOYEES EVEN THOSE COMPANIES
DIRECT THE DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES
AND IT IS IN THAT CONTEXT OF
MAJOR CHANGES.
THAT AUTOMATION. THE USE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
OTHER OF TE AT THE TRENDS THAT
ON YOU WILL ALSO BE SPEAKING
ABOUT ARE TAKING PLACE IN. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT I WOULD SAY SOME
OF THE IMPACTS OF THOSE CHANGES.
ON EARNINGS ON WAGES ON
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR LABOR LAWS
ON ACCESSIBILITY TO BAN BENEFITS
HAVE BEEN AMPLIFIED IN MAKE WORK
MADE WORSE.
SO LET ME.
JUST QUICKLY ILLUSTRATE WHAT I
MEAN BY THE FEATURED WORKPLACE I
COULD GIVE YOU EXAMPLES FROM
VIRTUALLY EVERY INDUSTRY.
AND I COULD GIVE YOU EXAMPLES
NOT ONLY AFFECTING LOW WAGE
WORKERS BUT INCREASINGLY WORKERS
WITH HIGHER LEVELS OF SKILLED
WORKERS EVEN WITH GRADUATE
DEGREES.
EVEN LAWYERS ARE BEING AFFECTED
BY BY THESE CHANGES BUT THEY
PROFOUNDLY HIT WORKING PEOPLE
WHO ARE OF LOWER WAGES AND OFTEN
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES.
IN THE EXAMPLE I WANT TO GIVE
YOU IS FROM RETAILING.
AYE HUGE TRANSFORMATION IN THE
WAY THAT GOODS ARE BROUGHT TO
STORES AND MORE RECENTLY TO OUR
OWN FRONT DOORS A BECAUSE OF A
TRANSFORMATION OF THAT I'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. THE PICTURE THE
SLIDE I HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU IS
OF A DISTRIBUTION CENTER OF A
MAJOR RETAILER. ODDS TO PART OF
RETAIL DISTRIBUTION WE OFTEN
DON'T SEE BUT IT'S REALLY THE
HEART OF MODERN RETELLING OF
SOMETIMES CALLED LEAN RETELLING.
WHERE YOU HAVE ON ONE HAND ON
ONE SIDE OF THAT BIG BUILDING
TRUCKS COMING IN OF FROM
SUPPLIERS BRINGING GOODS OF THAT
ARE DESTINED FOR THE STORES OF
THAT RETAILER? IN ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT DISTRIBUTION
CENTER.
AT WHAT'S CALLED THE CROSS
DOCKING FACILITY YOU ABOUT DOWN
TRUCKS THAT WILL BE DESTINED TO
SPECIFIC. US STORES WITH
SPECIFIC DELIVERIES.
THE CHANGE THAT HAPPENED IN
RETAILING IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES REALLY LED BY WALMART
BUT SPREADING ACROSS ENTIRE
INDUSTRY WAS TO CHANGE WHAT WAS
USED TO BE CALLED THE WAREHOUSE
INTO A DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
WHERE YOU HAVE INCOMING
SHIPMENTS OF GOODS YOU CAN SEE
IN THE LOWER?
HERE ARE COMING IN.
ELECTRONIC SYSTEMS HIGHLY
AUTOMATED INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGIES WHERE THOSE GOODS
ARE UNLOADED USUALLY FROM TRUCK
SOMETIMES FROM CONTAINERS. BY
MANUAL LABOR BUT THEN QUIT ON
AUTOMATED INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
CONTROLLED SYSTEMS THAT MOVE
THOSE GOOD SOMETIMES WITHIN
THREE MINUTES TO OUTGOING DOCKS
WHERE AGAIN INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY TELLS.
.
THE THE SYSTEM EXACTLY WHICH
STORE THAT DELIVERY SHOULD GO
TO.
POT SO YOU HAVE A LOT OF MANUAL
WORK ON THE INCOMING DECK A LOT
OF MANUAL WORK ON THE OUTGOING
DECK AND THEN VERY ADVANCED
AUTOMATED SYSTEMS. UP THAT WHOLE
SYSTEM WORKS BECAUSE RETAILERS
HAVE VERY SPECIFIC HIGHLY
TECHNICAL STANDARDS
THAT THEY NEED EVERYONE TO MAKE
WHETHER IT'S THE SUPPLIER OR THE
TRUCK DRIVERS WHO WERE COMING IN
AND OUT OF THE FACILITIES.
.
AND THOSE STANDARDS AND
REQUIREMENTS ARE DICTATED BY THE
BUSINESS STRATEGIES OF COMPANIES
WE KNOW WELL LIKE WALMART AND
AND.
AMAZON.
NOW WHAT HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS IS WHO DOES THAT WORK AND
WHERE AS ONCE THE STORY I JUST
DESCRIBED EVERYONE IN THE IN THE
FACILITY WHERE EMPLOYEES OF THE
RETAILER. OF THAT'S NO LONGER
THE CASE.
SOMEWHERE IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES A MAJOR RETAILER
STARTED TO SAY WELL LET'S HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE RUN THOSE
FACILITIES FOR US LET'S HIRE
COMPANIES LIKE SCHNEIDER
LOGISTICS IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
GLOBAL PLAYERS IN THIS. AREA.
TO RUN IT BY OUR SPEX TO OUR
STANDARDS AND WILL BE PENALIZED
AND PAID BASED ON THEIR ABILITY
TO DO THAT BUT IT'S THEIR
PROBLEM TO ACTUALLY RUN.
EMPLOYEE THE PEOPLE PAY THE
PEOPLE AND SO ON.
THAT'S LEVEL ONE OF FEATURING
BUT THAT'S NOT WHERE IT STOPPED
LEVEL TO A FEATURING HAS BEEN.
THAT WAS WORK FORCES ARE
INCREASINGLY NOT THE EMPLOYEES
OF THE THIRD PARTY LOGISTICS
OPENING THE THIRD PARTY
LOGISTICS COMPANY GOES OUT AND
HIRES STAFFING AGENCY.
AND THOSE WORKERS ARE PAID BY
THE STAFFING AGENCY AND
SOMETIMES HE IT THE FILTERING
GOES UN ONE FURTHER LEVEL WHERE
THE STAFFING AGENCY PAYS THOSE
WORKERS AS IF THEY'RE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AS IF
THEY'RE NOT EVEN THEIR EMPLOYEES
BUT THEY'RE BEING PAID ON A
PIECE RATE BASIS. UMP THAT'S
WHERE WHEN I WAS IN MY WAGE AN
HOUR HAD WE OFTEN FOUND FLAGRANT
VIOLATIONS OF NOT ONLY OVER TIME
IN JUST THE BASIC IDEA THAT YOU
SHOULD PAY PEOPLE FOR WORK. BUT
EVEN THE MINIMUM WAGE WOULD BE
VIOLATED IN THOSE SETTINGS.
AND SO THAT'S THE FEATURED
WORKPLACE WHERE YOU HAVE STILL
THE COMPANY THAT WE ALL KNOW
DICTATING ALL THE STANDARD SICKO
WINE. BUT THE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP BROKEN APART INTO
MULTIPLE PIECES.
AND THAT'S THE STORY WOULD HAVE
TOLD YOU UP TILL ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO.
BUT THIS FEATURING STORY HAS
FEATURED FURTHER.
AND AGAIN JUST TO UNDERSCORE
AND SOMETHING THAT LINKS THE
DISCUSSION THAT I'M I'M PUTTING
ON THE TABLE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR MORE ABOUT.
IN IN OTHER SESSIONS.
THE USE OF UBER TYPE PLATFORM
ECONOMIES TO CHANGE THIS EVEN
FURTHER.
AND WHAT I WOULD NOW JUST POINT
NOW IS THAT INSTEAD OF THE
SYSTEMS TRYING TO BRING GOODS TO
PHYSICAL STORES. IT'S NOW THE
GAME IS TO GET GOODS DIRECTLY
FOR HOME DELIVERY WHETHER THAT
IS.
SOFT GOODS A KIND OF THINGS WE
BY WALMART OR GROCERIES.
AND ONCE AGAIN THAT IS BEING
DONE BY USING A NETWORK OF
BROKEN APART EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIPS SO WHAT RETAILERS
AND TYPICALLY COMPANIES LIKE
AMAZON ARE NOW DOING IS USING AN
INTERMEDIARY SET UP. WANT
SOMETIMES SINGLE CONTRACTOR
SOMETIMES MULTIPLE CONTRACTORS.
TO PICK UP THOSE GOODS.
AND THEN ROUTE THEM TO A NETWORK
OF CARS.
AND WHERE THE CARS ARE MUCH LIKE
WE SEE IN PLATFORM
TRANSPORTATION ARE BEING OWNED
AND OPERATED BY INDIVIDUALS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS EVEN
THOUGH THOSE COULD BILL WAS
THERE THEIR MOVEMENT THERE IT
COMPENSATION THEIR TIING THEIR
STANDARDS ARE ALL STILL DICTATED
BY THE. BEAT THE RETAILER AND SO
WHAT YOU HAVE EVEN MORE SO IN
THIS MODERN SYSTEM OF RETAILING.
IS.
A MODELING OF WHO IS THE
EMPLOYER.
THE MINUTE YOU CREATE I'M
TRAINED IN ECONOMICS AND YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S ALMOST AXIOMATIC
THAT IF YOU BREAK APART. BUG OUT
A MARKET IN THE MULTIPLE PIECES
EVERYONE ASK TO GET THEIR
PROFIT.
AND THAT MEANS WHAT'S LEFT AT
THE BOTTOM GET SMALLER AND
SMALLER AND IN PARTICULAR IF THE
ONLY THING YOU HAVE LEFT TO
CONTROL. ARE YOUR LABOR COSTS
ARE UNFORTUNATELY IT'S WORKING
PEOPLE WHO BEAR THE RISK OF
THESE THESE CHANGES. AND SO THE
TRANSFORMATION THAT I I'VE JUST
OUTLINED TO YOU HAS RIPPLED
ACROSS OUR ECONOMY.
.
I WON'T GO INTO THE DETAILS OF
THE SLIDE BUT I'LL JUST SIMPLY
TELL YOU. THAT A ONE OF THE TWO
OF THE MOST DISTINGUISHED LABOR
ECONOMISTS IN THIS FIELD HAVE
ESTIMATED. THAT NINETY FOUR
PERCENT.
NINETY FOUR PERCENT OF NET
EMPLOYMENT GROWTH IN THIS
ECONOMY FROM TWO THOUSAND FIVE
TO TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
A ROSE FROM THESE KINDS OF
RELATIONSHIPS
THAT VIRTUALLY ALL THE NET NEW
JOBS CREATED WERE IN THE FORM OF
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTING ON CALL
WORKERS TEMPORARY HELP STAFFING
AGENCIES. OR WORKERS PROVIDED BY
SOME OTHER KIND OF CONTRACT FIRM
A THAT'S A LEVEL OF GROWTH OF IT
TYPE OF WORK PRACTICE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THIS ECONOMY. I IN MY MIND
EVER AND IT'S IN THAT CONTEXT
THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND AS I SAY THAT THE
FUTURE OF WORKERS HERE.
.
THE LAST POINT BY I WOULD MAKE
IN CLOSING IS THAT.
EVERYTHING I'VE JUST DESCRIBED
TO YOU HAS BEEN MADE BY THE
CONSCIOUS CHOICES OF BUSINESSES
MAKING DECISIONS OFTEN BECAUSE
OF INTENSE PRESSURES THEY FACED
FROM CAPITAL MARKETS FROM
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC CAPITAL
MARKETS.
WHO HAVE FORCED COMPANIES
INCREASINGLY TO FOCUS ON CORE
COMPETENCIES AND FIND WAYS TO
REDUCE OUR COSTS? THESE ARE
CHOICES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
THESE ARE CHOICES THAT
SOMETIMES.
CUT AGAINST THE GRAIN OF OUR
BASIC STRUCTURE OF STANDARDS.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT.
HAVE NOT ONLY SHIFTED A LOT OF
THE COSTS OF THESE PRACTICES ON
TO WORKING PEOPLE ARE BUT ALSO
REQUIRE US TO RETHINK OUR WHOLE
APPROACH TO REGULATING THE LABOR
MARKET.
THANK YOU.
CONDUCT DAVID THOUGHT DAVID
MISTER WHILE.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE PRESENCE
OF SENATOR WACHOWSKI I WILL HEAR
ARE FROM DR BERNARD BUT DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS
SIR. OKAY THANK YOU I'M WILL
COME BACK WITH QUESTIONS FOR
BOTH OF YOU NUMBER PLEASE NOW
HAVE GOT THE BURKHARDT.
A WONDERFUL WELL GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY THANK YOU THE CHAIR
IS.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT OF
THE TWO COMMITTEES AND STAFF.
I AM VERY HONORED TO BE HERE TO
SPEAK WITH YOU AND TO SHARE
WHAT.
WE AT THE LABOR CENTER AND WITH
OUR ALLIES HAVE FIGURED OUT
AROUND WHETHER THE ROBOTS ARE
COMING IN WHETHER WE'RE GONNA
HAVE AN APOCALYPSE OR NOT. BUT I
JUST WANT TO SAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PAIRING ON THIS
PANEL OF THE TWO OF US. I THINK
IT'S VERYEASY AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW WHEN YOU DIVE INTO THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY DEBATES TO GET TUNNEL
VISION AND TO THINK IT'S ALL
GOING TO BE ABOUT TECHNOLOGY.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE DAVID'S
PERSPECTIVE THAT THERE IS A
NUMBER OF LONG TERM TRENDS HERE
IN THE LABOR MARKET AND
TECHNOLOGY WILL INCREASINGLY BE
PART OF THOSE TRENDS BUT IT'S
NOT THE ONLY ISSUE. THAT SAID IT
IS A BIG ISSUE AND.
I. I THINK WE ARE AT A
DIFFERENT POINT NOW THAN WE WERE
A YEAR AGO I THINK A YEAR AGO
AND THE RESEARCH AND POLICY
DEBATES WE WERE STILL VERY MUCH
IN THIS MODE OF. WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE MASSIVE JOB LOSS IN THE U.
S. YOU GUYS HAVE SEEN THE
STATISTICS YOU KNOW FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF JOBS WILL BE LOST IN
THE U. S.. I THINK NOW WE ARE IN
A DIFFERENT PLACE DUE IN PART TO
REALLY GREAT RESEARCH BY
MCKINSEY.
AND I WILL JUST GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF TOP LINES HERE I THINK
THAT CURRENT RESEARCH IS
SUGGESTING THAT WE ARE UNLIKELY
TO HAVE MASSIVE JOB DISPLACEMENT
IN THE NEAR AND MEDIUM TERM.
WE CAN TALK MORE ABOUT THAT
STUDY DURING DISCUSSION.
BUT THEY DO ESTIMATED THAT THEY
THINK THAT THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
THAT THE U. S. WILL HAVE ENOUGH
JOB GROWTH. AT LEAST AT TWENTY
THIRTY AND SO TO ME THE QUESTION
THEN BECOMES.
NOT THAT ONE IS NOT WORKING.
.
WHAT IS GOING TO BE THE QUALITY
OF THE JOBS?
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
HOWARD THESE CHANGES GOING TO
IMPACT VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IMMIGRANT
WORKERS WOMEN IT CETERA.
AND IF THAT'S THE QUESTION THEN
I THINK.
OUR PUBLIC POLICY HEARING
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE PRO
INNOVATION ABSOLUTELY BUT WE
HAVE TO PUT WORKERS AND IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES.
AT THE CENTER OF THE DISCUSSION.
LET ME TO SHOW YOU A COUPLE MORE
SLIDES HERE.
.
I'M JUST I'M TRYING TO TURN DOWN
PER YOUR SUGGESTION.
.
IF WE ARE NOT LOOKING OTHER
ROBOTS APOCALYPSE THIS IS THE
GRAPH I THINK WE HAVE TO CARRY
WITH US OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN SO THIS GRAPH SHOWS THE
GROWTH AND PRODUCTIVITY IN THE
U. S SINCE THE WORK POST WORLD
WAR TWO ERA. AND IT SHOWS THE
GROWTH IN HOURLY COMPENSATION IE
WAGES AND I'M SURE YOU GUYS HAVE
SEEN THIS GRAPH BEFORE STARTING
IN THE MID SEVENTIES THAT SOCIAL
CONTRACT BROKE APART. AND OUR
PRODUCTIVITY GAINS WERE NOT
SHARED WITH WORKERS.
AND THE REASON I FLAG THIS IS
BECAUSE AMONG ECONOMISTS AND A
LOT OF POLICYMAKERS THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT ECONOMIC
GROWTH IN THE U. S. GOING
FORWARD. PEOPLE REALLY ARE I'M
ARE FOCUSED ON ARE WE GONNA HAVE
ENOUGH PRODUCTIVITY GROWTH AND
SO YOU WILL SEE ARGUMENTS AND
I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD THIS.
THAT WE SHOULD BE AYE INVESTING
EVEN MUCH MORE THAN WE ARE NOW
IN NEW TECHNOLOGY TO GET THE
PRODUCTIVITY GROWTH SO THAT OUR
ECONOMY CONTINUES TO GROW. AND
BUT I WOULD SAY IS WE CANNOT
HAVE THAT DEBATE WITHOUT ALSO
FOCUSING ON THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE GAMES.
OTHERWISE I THINK THE DEFAULT
WILL BE THERE'S A THERE'S
SEVERAL ECONOMISTS WHO ARE
ARGUING THAT NEW TECHNOLOGY WILL
JUST SERVE TO EXACERBATE
INEQUALITY. IF WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING ELSE SO JUST FOCUSING
ON PRODUCTIVITY GROWTH IN MY
MIND IS NOT ENOUGH AND I DON'T
THINK THIS IS AN EITHER OR LIKE
YOU GUYS HAVE HAVE MENTIONED IN
YOUR OPENING REMARKS. I THINK
THERE IS A WAY WE CAN HAVE
PRODUCTIVITY GROWTH NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND.
SHARE IT WITH WORKERS.
.
HERE IS.
A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES I HAVE OF.
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE AND I'M NOT GOING TO GO TO
ALL OF THEM BUT I WILL FLAG AND
THIS IS COMING FROM NEW RESEARCH
THAT WE ARE COMMISSIONING WE
HAVE COMMISSIONED A SERIES OF
INDUSTRY STUDIES AROUND THE
LIKELY IMPACTS OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES.
IN YOU ALL HAVE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT LONG HAUL TRUCKING IN THE
COMING ABOUT TIME LIMITS TRUCKS
AND HOW WOULD THEY LIKE LEAD TO
DISPLACE THREE MILLION LONG HAUL
TRUCKERS THESE ARE THE GUYS WHO
MOVE STUFF ON THE HIGHWAYS.
OUR RESEARCH IS SUGGESTING THAT
WE WILL ACTUALLY THOUGH ALSO SEE
A GROWTH IN TRUCKING JOBS IN
SHORT HAUL TRUCKING AND
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF THE
GOODNESS OF TO ONLINE RETAIL IN
THE GROWTH OF WAREHOUSES.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED A LOT MORE.
FOLKS MOVING STUFF BETWEEN
WAREHOUSES AND FULFILLMENT
CENTERS AND THEN TO CONSUMERS
AND THE KEY QUESTION IS WHAT IS
GOING TO BE THE QUALITY OF THOSE
JOBS. THAT SHORT HAUL TRUCKING
JOB IS NOW IN THE TOP TEN LIST
ON MONSTER DOT COM IN TERMS OF
JOB OPENINGS BUT YOU CAN.
IMAGINE THAT ONE OF THE DEFAULT
SCENARIOS WILL BE THAT THESE
WILL BE GIG JOBS.
THAT THEY WILL BE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND THEY WILL PICK
UP SHORT PACKAGE DELIVERY IN
MOVEMENT BETWEEN WAREHOUSES BUT
THIS IS NOT INEVITABLE.
AND I THINK THE QUESTION FOR US
IS POLICYMAKERS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
IS WHAT ARE WE GOING TO ASK OF
THE WAREHOUSES WHEN THEY COME
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
CAN WE IMAGINE THE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE NEW
TRUCKING JOBS WILL ACTUALLY BE
EMPLOYEES AND THAT THEY WILL BE
AND HOUSE JOBS RIGHT AND WE CAN
MAKE THAT DECISION WE CAN MAKE
THAT FUTURE.
ON THE OTHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM SORT OF MORE IN TERMS
OF OPPORTUNITIES.
I'M HOPEFUL STORIES IN THE
HEALTHCARE SECTOR THERE IS AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGE THAT.
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME AND HAS
BEEN HAPPENING FOR AWHILE.
AND IN CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A REALLY INTERESTING
EXAMPLE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER WITH KAISER.
AND SO AS YOU KNOW KAISER IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND IN THE COUNTRY.
AND HAS A LABOR MANAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIP AND THAT LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP DOES A
LOT OF DELIBERATIONS BETWEEN
KAISER AND ITS UNIONS ABOUT HOW
NEW TECHNOLOGIES ARE GOING TO
IMPACT WORKERS IN THE WORKPLACE.
AND IN FACT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
KAISER.
WHEN THEY IMPLEMENTED
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS THEY
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THEIR
WORKERS IN WITH THEIR UNIONS AND
IT IS WIDELY CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE BEST EXAMPLES OF ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORDS.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF BAD
EXAMPLES AS YOU GUYS PROBABLY
KNOW SO IN MY MIND THAT IS THE
VISION THAT WE WANT AND I THINK
IN IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
EXAMPLES THAT WE CAN DRAW ON.
WHERE WORKERS ARE ACTUALLY
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS ITSELF OF
IMPLEMENTING NEW TECHNOLOGIES?
AND SO I LEAVE YOU WOULD.
.
I AM NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH
THIS.
THIS IS OUR GRADE THAT WE ARE
USING RIGHT NOW TO IDENTIFY
AREAS WHERE WE NEED PUBLIC
POLICY DEVELOPMENT AND WE CAN GO
BACK TO THIS IF WE WANT. I'D I
THINK YOU ALL KNOW WE HAVE VERY
LITTLE RIGHT NOW THAT FOLKS HAVE
DEVELOPED IN TERMS OF POLICY
RESPONSES WHEN IT COMES TO
DISPLACEMENT OR OR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING AT CETERA.
I THINK MY CONCERN IS THAT WE DO
POLICY MAKING IN THIS AREA ON AN
AD HOC BASIS.
OR IN SORT OF WHACK A MOLE FORM
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE SOME ON
RAMP TIME HERE RIGHT THIS IS NOT
ALL HAPPENING TOMORROW. LET US
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE VISION
THAT WE HAVE A WHAT WE WANT
TECHNOLOGY TO DO AND LET'S ASK
BIG QUESTIONS THAT WILL PROVIDE
A FRAMEWORK FOR PUBLIC POLICY
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO
HERE ARE SOME BIG QUESTIONS.
WHAT WOULD IT TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY EDUCATION TRAINING AND
SAFETY NET SYSTEM LOOK LIKE?
HOW DO WE ENSURE OUR ECONOMY
GROWS GOOD JOBS AND IN MY MIND
WHERE WORKERS WORK ALONGSIDE AND
WOOD TECHNOLOGY?
REDUCE ECONOMIC INEQUALITY AND
ESPECIALLY RACE AND GENDER BIAS?
AND THEN PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANT
WHAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
EMPLOYERS IN ANSWERING THESE
QUESTIONS AND IN PARTICULAR THE
TECH SECTOR. THERE ARE MANY MORE
QUESTIONS LIKE THIS BUT I THINK
THE USE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
SHOULD BE THE STARTING PLACE
BEFORE WE DIVE INTO SORT OF THE
MY MUSHA. OF SPECIFIC PIECES OF
PUBLIC POLICY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH FOR
GIVING US KIND OF A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW.
WILL TURN TO.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I GUESS THAT'LL BE ME
FOR NOW.
.
YOU KNOW I I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
FROM EITHER OF YOU HOW YOU VIEW.
HOW SHOULD WE BE GOING FORWARD
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION?
ABOUT WHERE AUTOMATION IS
HEADED UP AS A AS A CHAIR OF THE
LABOR COMMITTEE.
I VIEW MY NUMBER ONE JOB TO
LOOK OUT FOR THE INTERESTS OF
WORKING PEOPLE IN THE STATE AND.
THE FOLKS IN LABOR OUR PARTNERS
FOR THAT REASON BOB WE HAVE
OTHER PARTNERS TO.
WE HAVE PARTNERS WE HEAR FROM
TODAY IN THE IN THE TECH SECTOR
WHO WILL TALK ABOUT WHERE
INNOVATION EXISTS.
TO THE DEGREE THAT WE CAN HOW
DO WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS GOING
FORWARD THAT MIGHT BE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS ON BUT WHAT SHOULD
WE BE TALKING ABOUT WHERE ARE
THE OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE.
DESPITE WHAT YOU SAID DR I I YOU
KNOW EVERYTHING WE HEAR IS ALL
THESE JOBS ARE GOING TO BE LOST
AND AND AND AND YOUR DATA
SUGGESTS.
DIFFERENT PHENOMENA.
I IN I HAVE TO SAY THIS IS A
SPACE THAT I NEVER THOUGHT WOULD
OCCUR.
WHEN I HEARD PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT. THE YOU KNOW AUTOMATION I
THOUGHT ABOUT CARTOONS I WATCHED
AS A KID WHERE THEY WERE ROBOTS
DOING THINGS FOR PEOPLE AND THEN
THE NEXT THING I HEARD THAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE EIGHTEEN
WHEELERS THAT WERE SOFT DRIVING.
TRUCKS DOING LONG HALLS AND SO
CLEARLY THE TECHNOLOGY IS HERE
HAS ARRIVED OF FROM YOUR
STANDPOINT HOW WHAT CONVERSATION
SHOULD WE BE HAVING GOING
FORWARD. AS A LABOR COMMUNITY
TECHNOLOGY A COMPANY'S BUSINESS
TOGETHER OF MOVING FOR.
NOW I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
REALLY SURE I AM NOT PAINTING A
ROSY PICTURE HERE.
SO.
JUST BECAUSE I'M SAYING
RESURGENT RIGHT NOW IS
SUGGESTING WE ARE NOT GONNA HAVE
AN IMMINENT ROBOTS APOCALYPSE WE
KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANT DISPLACEMENT OF
WORKERS. WE WILL NEED TO RETRAIN
WORKERS ON THE JOB WE WILL WE
WILL NEED TO FIND NEW JOBS FOR
PEOPLE WHO TOTALLY LOSE OUR JOBS
ALTOGETHER THERE IS A REAL.
POLICY CHALLENGE HERE AND WE CAN
NAVIGATE WE CAN GO THROUGH THIS.
NEXT TRANSITION.
IN A PAINFUL WAY OR WE CAN DO
IN WAYS THAT TAKE CARE OF
WORKERS SIDE I DON'T PAINT TOO
ROSY A PICTURE. I THINK THERE'S
TWO PIECES HERE ONE IS.
WE NEED TO BE INVESTING AND WE
CAN PARTNER WE SHOULD BE
PARTNERING WITH YOU WHILE WE
NEED TO BE INVESTING AND THE
TYPE OF. REALLY CONCRETE
RESEARCH INTO PARTICULAR
INDUSTRIES TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
COMING DOWN THE PIPELINE IN THE
NEAR AND MEDIUM TERM I THINK WE
HAVE REACHED DOES SORT OF THE.
LIMITS OF WHAT THE SORT OF
MACKENZIE TYPE STUDIES CAN TEACH
US THEIR VERY AGGREGATE VERY
HIGH LEVEL. I THINK IN ORDER FOR
YOU ALL TO ACT AND IN ORDER FOR
UNIONS TO ACT WE NEED TO KNOW
LIKE IN THE GROCERY STORE
INDUSTRY WHAT ARE THE THREE
TRENDS WEARS JOB GROWTH LIKELY
TO BE. WHERE WE GONNA LOSE IT
WHERE ARE OUR LEVERAGE POINTS
RIGHT AND SO THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
INVESTED IN THAT TYPE OF
RESEARCH AND THIS IS GOING TO BE
AN ON GOING? BY NEED FOR MORE
AND MORE INFORMATION FROM THE
FIELD. AND THEN I WOULD SAY
SECOND.
WE HAD A VERY INTERESTING A
VISIT FROM A DELEGATION FROM
DENMARK.
TWO WEEKS AGO AND I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU THAT IN EUROPE EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THE E. U. MEMBER
COUNTRIES HAS A NATIONAL.
INITIATIVE TRIPARTITE WITH
EMPLOYERS GOVERNMENT AND UNIONS
AT THE TABLE TO BEGIN THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
WORK. FOR TO FIND AREAS OF
COMMON INTEREST AND TO BEGIN TO
PUT UP PLAN ACTUAL PROGRAMMING.
AND IT IS AMAZING TO ME THAT
THE U. S. DOES NOT HAVE A
PROCESS LIKE THAT I THINK THAT
IS GOING TO HAVE TO HAPPEN AT
THE STATE LEVEL FRANKLY.
AND YOU KNOW
I'M WAY AS WARY AS ANYBODY ELSE
OF PUTTING TOGETHER A NEW BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION BUT AS YOU
SAID THIS DOES HAVE TO START
WITH A JOINT ONVERSATION WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AT THE
TABLE. AND I AM HAPPY TO SHARE
WITH YOU.
THE BLUEPRINTS OF WHAT
COUNTRIES LIKE DENMARK AND
GERMANY ARE DOING GERMANY LAUNCH
RT THREE YEARS AGO WHAT THEY
CALL THEIR INDUSTRY FOUR POINT.
INITIATIVE AND THEY ARE VERY
INTENT ON MAKING SURE THAT THEIR
COUNTRY IS A LEADER IN ADOPTING
NEW TECHNOLOGY.
IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT.
AND UP DISPLACING AND HURTING A
LOT OF WORKERS DAY RT SEVERAL
YEARS AHEAD OF WHERE WE ARE IN
THE U. S. IN THAT CONVERSATION.
AND SO WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SHARE SOME OF THOSE MODELS WITH
YOU IN THINKING THAT THROUGH.
I WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL THANK
YOU.
MISTER WHILE COULD YOU TALK
ABOUT THE TYPES OF.
JOBS THAT YOU SEE BEING TREATED
AS A RESULT. OF AUTOMATION
PEOPLE KEEP SAYING THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ALL THESE JOBS
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE.
TO SERVICE IF YOU WILL.
YOU KNOW THE EQUIPMENT THE
TECHNOLOGY.
IN YOUR RESEARCH HAVE YOU FOUND
THAT TO BE THE CASE IN THE SO OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE.
OR IS THAT SOMETHING WHERE
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A PHD AND I
ENGINEERING.
TO DISSIPATE.
WELL I I THINK THE ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION. COMES TO A
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE OF.
IT'S A CHOICE IT'S HOW WE
STRUCTURE JOBS IN THE FUTURE.
ARE BASED ON THE CHOICES THAT
EMPLOYERS MAKE THAT PUBLIC
POLICIES DIRECT US TOWARDS BED.
HAVING PEOPLE ARE HAVING
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE UNIONS.
AND WORKER REPRESENTATIVES AT
THE TABLE WILL AFFECT.
YOU KNOW I WOULD I WOULD GO
BACK TO WHAT SORT OF YOUR FIRST
QUESTION IN AND THINKING ABOUT
THE QUESTION YOU JUST ASKED ME.
THERE IS ALWAYS THIS TEMPTATION.
AMONG BOTH ECONOMISTS.
AND TECHNOLOGY PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT THESE CHANGES AS IF THEY
ARE FORCES OF NATURE THAT THEY
ARE ON ALL TERRIBLE AND THAT
SORT OF. GET OVER IT THIS IS THE
WAY THE WORLD IS ORGANIZED.
MARKETS MOVE IN CERTAIN WAYS
BECAUSE OF ECONOMIC FORCES BUT
THEY ARE STEERED BY SOCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE STEERED BY
GOVERNMENT POLICIES ARE STEERED
BY WHO SITTING AT THE TABLE WHEN
THOSE CHOICES ARE MADE.
AND SO.
I THOUGHT ANNETTA GAVE A GREAT
EXAMPLE THAT BUILDS ON THE
EXAMPLE I PUT ON A UP ON.
ON THE CHART.
THERE WILL UNDOUBTEDLY BE
CHANGES THAT WILL ARISE FROM THE
AUTOMATION OF TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS.
BUT THERE IS THE SECONDARY
PROBLEM WE'RE STILL GOING TO
HAVE TO GET PACKAGES TO PEOPLE'S
DOORS WERE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
RELYING ON HUMAN BEINGS FOR THAT
FOR QUITE SOMETIME.
HOW THOSE JOBS ARE DESIGNED?
IS VERY MUCH GOING TO BE A
FUNCTION OF HOW WE THINK ABOUT
WHO WE HAVE AT THE TABLE WHAT WE
HAVE IN TERMS OF EXPECTATIONS OF
EMPLOYERS ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO BE TREATING THAT
WORKFORCE. ITEM AND THAT WILL
THEN RIPPLE OUT TO HOW MUCH OF
THE ENORMOUS GAINS SAID ARE
BEING ENJOYED BY SOME OF OUR
HIGH TECH COMPANIES WILL BE
SHARED BY THEIR LABOR FORCE HOW
MUCH WILL BE SHARED BY THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
OPERATE. HOW MUCH OF THE RISK?
THE RISK THAT WORKING PEOPLE
FACE THAT HISTORICALLY WE ASK
EMPLOYERS TO HELP THEM WITH THAT
RISK AND WE HAD PUBLIC POLICIES
LIKE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
TO CUSHION THOSE RISKS HOW MUCH
OF THOSE RISK WILL BE SHIFTED
ONTO WORKING PEOPLE RIGHT NOW WE
ARE UNFORTUNATELY DRIFTING INTO
A SYSTEM.
WHERE THE IMPACTS OF SOME OF THE
AUTOMATION CHANGES HERE ASKING
ABOUT?
?
AND THE DOCTOR BERNHARDT
DESCRIBED ARE GOING TO RESULT IN
TWO RISKS BORN BY WORKING PEOPLE
AND HAVING A. WORSE AND WORSE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET AND GAINING
LESS AND LESS OF THE VALUE THEIR
CREATING IN THE FORM OF WAGES.
BUT AGAIN I GO BACK TO THE
PREMISE WHICH IS THAT SOCIAL
CHOICE RIGHT NOW THAT'S BECAUSE
WE HAVE LEFT OPEN CERTAIN SOCIAL
POLICIES ABOUT WHO IS AN
EMPLOYEE WHO IS AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR. REALLY TO BE DECIDED
BY. A EMPLOYERS AND DECIDED IN
THE BREACH RATHER THAN HAVING.
PURPOSIVE PUBLIC POLICIES THAT
REALLY MAKE IT CLEAR WHAT
PROTECTIONS WE WANNA HAVE OF
WORKING PEOPLE TO LIVE IN AND
THEN LETTING BUSINESSES MAKE
DECISIONS IN THE CONTEXT OF
THAT.
AM I GUESS YOU KNOW I'VE TAUGHT
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESS SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
BUSINESS SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
PEOPLE IN THEM IN IN IN THE IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR PRETTY
CLEVER.
THEY'LL FIGURE OUT WAYS TO MAKE
PROFITS WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF
CLEARLY DEFINED LAWS AND
EXPECTATIONS THAT'S WHAT I THINK
WE NEED THAT SOMETIMES OUTSIDE
THOSE BOUNDARIES ARE AND NOW
IT'S ABSOLUTELY.
I WOULD HEAR THE LABOR
PERSPECTIVES ONE FINAL QUESTION
REALLY ALONG THESE LINES YOU
BOTH REFERENCE.
THIS SOCIAL CHOICE IN THAT THERE
BE THE STRUCTURE SORT OF
CREATING EXPECTATIONS AND
GUIDELINES FOR HOW THE FUTURE OF
WORK PROCEEDS. IT YOU KNOW OUR
THEIR EXISTING STRUCTURES THAT
YOU CAN POINT TO OUTSIDE OF
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE IN MY
EXPERIENCE.
INNOVATORS CREATE.
THEY DON'T CONSULT GOVERNMENT
TO SAY WHAT RAGS WILL WE BE YOU
KNOW PASSED TO FOLLOW.
GOVERNMENT TYPICALLY.
REGULATES AFTER THE FACT LE.
INNOVATIONS GET CREATED AND THEN
GOVERNMENT HEARS ABOUT THINGS
THAT ARE GOOD AND SOMETIMES NOT
GOOD AND THEN GOVERNMENT TRIES
TO TREAT THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL SUPPORT BUSINESS.
AND PROTECT THE WORKERS OF THOSE
BUSINESS AT THE SAME TIME IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THE WORK WILL
MOVE FORWARD BEFORE GOVERNMENT
IS IN A POSITION TO REALLY SET
THOSE GUIDELINES ARE THERE OTHER
STRUCTURES THAT. EXIST NOW THAT
YOU SEE DOING JUST THAT.
AND SO.
HI HOW ARE YOU.
I DON'T WANNA GIVE I DO WANT TO
GIVE UP THE IDEA THAT WE AS.
GOVERNMENT CAN ACT QUICKLY
ENOUGH.
TO BEGIN TO SET UP THOSE
STRUCTURES.
I THINK ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
GOVERNANCE IS A REALLY GREAT
EXAMPLE WHERE.
IN THE TECH IN THE TECH SECTOR
ITSELF I'M EVEN HEADS OF THOSE
COMPANIES ARE STARTING TO SAY WE
NEED A FRAMEWORK FOR ETHICS ON
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE RIGHT.
AND HAVE ALREADY CREATED THEIR
OWN STRUCTURES LIKE THE
PARTNERSHIP ON A AYE.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE MOVING
QUICKLY TO SAY ACTUALLY THAT
SPACE.
FOR TALKING ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
GOALS OF TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT WE
OPTIMIZING FOR THAT SHOULD BE
BASED IN GOVERNMENT AND I HAVE
SEEN SOME INTERESTING BECAUSE IN
THE UK FOR ESTABLISHING A
GOVERNMENT BASED.
OVERSIGHT.
A STRUCTURE THAT DOES INCLUDE
THE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
THEMSELVES.
BUT WHERE GOVERNMENT IS THE ONE
THAT'S DOING THE CONVENING ON
RAISING THE QUESTIONS ABOUT.
TO WHAT ND AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO RAISE THAT UP.
IN PART AS A SECOND ANSWERED TO
THE PREVIOUS QUESTION.
WE.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT FIGURING
OUT WHO WILL BEAR THE RISK I
THINK WE SHOULD BE ASKING TO
WHAT AND.
AND WHAT DO WE ACTUALLY WANT
TECHNOLOGY TO DO. IN THE
ENGINEERING WORLD THEY CALL THIS
THE AUGMENTATION VERSES
AUTOMATION DECISION THERE IS A
DESIGN CHOICE HERE AYE WE'D JUST
DEVELOPING AND DESIGNING
TECHNOLOGIES JUST TO REDUCE
COSTS JUST TO REDUCE EFFICIENCY.
AND THEREFORE OFTEN RESULTING
DISPLACED WORKERS OR ARE WE
GOING TO DESIGN TECHNOLOGY TO
AUGMENT WORKERS I MAKE THEM MORE
PRODUCTIVE BUT THEY ARE STILL ON
THE JOB THIS IS NOT LIKE A SORT
OF A PIPE DREAM RIGHT THIS COMES
DOWN TO AT THE POINT IN THE
LABS.
WHAT ARE YOU CONCEIVABLE OF
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
MANUFACTURING ARE YOU GOING TO
LEVERAGE THE FACT THAT THERE IS
AN EXPERIENCED WORK ON THE
FLOOR?
AND SURROUND THAT WORKER WITH
NEW TECHNOLOGY OR YOU GONNA MAKE
THAT WORKER OBSOLETE AYE THING
IN INDUSTRY AFTER INDUSTRY THAT
IS THE KEY FIRST DECISION DEBT
WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
CIVIC SOCIETY AND HOW DOES LABOR
AND HOW DO WORKERS HAVE AN INPUT
ON BECAUSE THE AUTOMATION ROUTE
YOU KNOW PATH IS NOT INEVITABLE
IN MOST CASES?
IF YOU ARE ABLE TO WE LIKE YOU
TO STAY A TO HEAR FROM OUR LABOR
PERSPECTIVES FROM OUR BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVES. ITEM WE'RE GONNA
SEGUE TO THE LABOR.
PROSPECTUS PANEL PART OF THE
PANEL BUT.
WE'RE WE'RE HONORED THAT WE
HAVE.
THE SENATE CHAIR OF LABOR HERE
AND THAT WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME
HIM A IN HIS NEW OF ROLE I'M
EXCITED TO HAVE HIM AS A PARTNER
WE DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS BUT WE
CAN APPLAUD IN THIS HOUSE FOR A
NEW SENATE LABOR CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I CHAIR
THURMAN FOR THAT. TRADUCTION AND
DIED I'M THRILLED TO BE HERE AS
THE NEW CHAIR OF.
LABOR DUST RELATIONS THROUGH
THE US STATE SENATE.
.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS HEARING WHICH WAS READY UP
BEING ORGANIZED UP BEFORE WE
CAME CHAIR IS BEING HELD A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE NEED O
BE LOOKING.
DEL TOWARD THE FUTURE AND WHERE.
WHERE WE'RE GOING AND ALSO
ENSURING THAT?
?
THAT.
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE.
WORK FORCE AND THAT THAT WORK
FORCES IS READY FOR FOR THIS
FUTURE AND I THINK THERE ARE
DECISIONS TO BE MADE BOTH POLICY
DESIGN OTHER DECISIONS TO BE
MADE AS WELL AS I APPRECIATE
THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS HEARING
I'M VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD
TO.
HEARING.
AS MANY OF THE TEST FIRES I
APOLOGIZE BEFORE I KNEW WAS
LABOR CHAIR AT A FULL SCHEDULE
ALREADY.
SCHEDULED TODAY BUT I'M PLEASED
TO BE ABLE TO TO LEAST MAKE
SOMETIME TO BE UP TO SPEED AT
LEAST IN PART OF THIS HEARING
AND I LOOK FORWARD AGAIN WORKING
WITH THAT WITH CHAIRED THURMAN'S
WELL AS A. AS A STRONG PARTNER
BEING SURE THAT.
WE.
FIGHT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE SO THANK YOU THINK
STRUCTURE HAVE YEAH I THINK OUT
OF OUR PRESENTERS HERE FOR FOR
BEING HERE AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT WE WILL NOW
HEAR SOME LABOR PERSPECTIVES WE
HAVE A A FEW PANELISTS THAT TO
COME FORWARD REPRESENTING. OF
THE TEAMSTERS AND HE LEADS OF
THE TEAM SERVICE THROUGHOUT ALL
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
DUBBED BLOCK.
REPRESENTING THE UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
THAT THE WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
WE HAVE JIM LEHRER BE.
REPRESENTING SEIU WE HAVE T. OR.
WILL BE OUR PRESENTERS.
WELCOME AND.
WE ARE READY WHENEVER YOU ARE
THE SABAKI ELECTED LEADERS ARE.
THANK YOU.
.
AND BEFORE I START TO CESAR DE
HAS FROM THE BUILDING TRADES.
SENSES APOLOGIES HE WAS A FELLOW
PANELISTS BUT HE STUCK IN
COMMITTEE BUT HE WANTED TO BE
HERE THIS MORNING.
I AM SO GOOD MORNING CHAIRS
THURMAN AND PAN.
AS WAS SAID MY NAME'S DOUG
BLOCK AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
TEAMSTERS. FROM BAKERSFIELD UP
TO THE OREGON BORDER.
AND FOR PURPOSES OF TODAY'S
DISCUSSION I WANT TO FOCUS
MOSTLY ON OUR MEMBERS WHO DRIVE
TRUCKS.
BUSES TRAINS AND ARE DOING
PACKAGE DELIVERY.
WHO ARE VULNERABLE TO
AUTOMATION?
THIS ISSUE IS SO IMPORTANT TO
OUR UNION AND THAT IN THE MIDST
OF ALL MY OTHER DUTIES AND
SPENDING MORE THAN HALF MY TIME
ON IT.
SO I WANNA THANK YOU FOR THIS
HEARING. ALSO MONO EXPRESSED MY
DEEP DISAPPOINTMENT THAT THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ARE NOT HERE. BECAUSE THIS IS
RIGHT UP HERE WITH RIGHT TO WORK
AS AN EXACT STANSHALL THREAT FOR
OUR UNION.
I HAVE.
TRAVEL ON THIS ISSUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO SILICON VALLEY HE
HERE. TO WASHINGTON DC.
AND EVERYWHERE I GO I HEAR TALK
ABOUT THIS ROBOT APOCALYPSE THAT
HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO.
ESTIMATES OF UP TO FOUR MILLION
WORKERS IN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THEIR JOBS IN
THIS COUNTRY IN THE NEXT FIVE TO
TWENTY YEARS.
I DON'T BUY IT.
COURSE THE TEMPTATION IS TO COME
HERE THIS MORNING AND SAY.
WE'RE GOING TO STAKE OUT A
RIGHTEOUS POSITION AGAINST
AUTOMATION AND TECHNOLOGY. AND
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU.
AS LABOR ENDORSED DEMOCRATS TO
JOIN US AS WE WAGE WAR AGAINST
THE MACHINES.
NOW YOU ALL REMEMBER THE
LUDDITES RIGHT THESE WERE.
TEXTILE WORKERS IN ENGLAND WHO
DESTROYED THE WEAVING MACHINES
DURING THE INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF FUN TO
ME.
BUT THAT.
THE TEAMSTERS ARE NOT LUDDITES.
BUT WE'RE ALSO NOT GONNA PLAY
INTO ANY LINES FROM INDUSTRY
INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVES THAT WE
ARE OUT TO STIFLE INNOVATION.
IN FACT.
THE WORK THAT THE TEAMSTERS ARE
DOING AROUND THESE ISSUES IS
TRULY INNOVATIVE.
FOR WERE WORKING TO BUILD THE
FUTURE WHERE TECHNOLOGY AUGMENTS
JOBS DOESN'T AUTOMATE THEM.
WHAT GOVERNMENT WRITES THE RULES
TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL THE
PARTIES INVOLVED NOT JUST THE
COMPANIES WHO ARE DEVELOPING THE
TECHNOLOGY?
AND WHERE TECHNOLOGY MAKES
WORKERS JOB SAFER AND MORE
PRODUCTIVE AND WHERE IT
INCREASES THEIR EARNING POWER.
NOW THIS MAY ALL SOUND PIE IN
THE SKY SO LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
REAL LIFE EXAMPLES AND SEEING IS
ALL POLITICS ARE LOCAL MINI
SKIRT AND SAN FRANCISCO.
WHERE HAVE AN OFFICE?
LAST YEAR ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
PROPOSED A BAN ON PERSONAL
DELIVERY ROBOTS.
NOW WE WENT AND MET WITH ONE OF
THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
DEVELOPING THESE ROBOTS AND IT
QUICKLY BECAME CLEAR. THAT THIS
IS TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD
ACTUALLY HELP OUR MEMBERS WHO DO
PACKAGE DELIVERY.
INSTEAD OF PULLING UP TO A CURB
AND BREAKING THEIR BACK STACKING
BOXES AND LUGGING AROUND ON HAND
TRUCKS.
THEY COULD DROP A RAMP AND
DISPATCH SEVERAL THESE ROBOTS TO
DO REMOTE CONTROLLED DELIVERIES.
THEREBY DELIVERING MORE AND
DOING IT WITH LESS INJURIES.
SO WE WORKED WITH THE SUPERVISOR
TO AMEND THE LEGISLATION SO THAT
COMPANIES CAN GET PERMITS TO
TEST THESE ROBOTS BASED ON THE
FOLLOWING CONDITIONS.
ONE THEY HAD TO BE ACTUALLY
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
TO THEY HAD TO HAVE LABOR PEACE.
MEANING THESE HAD TO BE
COMPANIES THAT WERE CREATING.
GOOD LOCAL UNION JOBS.
AND WE WORKED OUT A DEAL WITH
ONE OF THE MANUFACTURERS SO THAT
WHEN THEY MOVE FROM THE TESTING
IN TO THE MANUFACTURING AND
DEPLOYMENT PHASE.
THESE ROBOTS ARE GOING TO BE
BUILT AND OPERATED BY TEAMSTERS.
WE STARTED OUT AS A UNION
OPERATING TEAMS OF HORSES WERE
GOING TO BE OPERATING TEAMS OF
ROBOTS.
THAT'S INNOVATION TO ME.
BACK HERE IN SACRAMENTO LAST
YEAR WE WORKED WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN.
AND A COMPANY CALLED PELOTON
TECHNOLOGY ON A BILL CALLED AB
SIX SIX NINE.
THAT MADE SURE THAT WHEN
PLATOONS OF TRUCKS ARE BEING
TESTED IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
THERE'S ONE TRUCK THAT'S
WIRELESSLY CONTROLLING A CONVOY.
THAT THERE'S A DRIVER WITH A
COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSE IN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
TRUCKS.
AND AFTER TESTIFYING IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
LAST MONTH I SPENT A LONG TIME
WITH THE HEAD OF INNOVATION FOR
VOLVO OF NORTH AMERICA. TALKING
TO THEM AND THEY AGREED THAT IF
YOU WANT TO DEVELOP NEW TRUCK
TECHNOLOGY THE FIRST THING YOU
SHOULD BE DOING IS ACTUALLY
TALKING TO A PERSON WHO DRIVES A
TRUCK.
THE BILL.
THIS IF THIS IS DONE RIGHT WITH
YOUR HELP THIS COULD ACTUALLY BE
GOOD FOR TRUCK DRIVERS IN INDIA
AND THE INDUSTRY.
BUT THAT BEING SAID NONE OF
THESE COMPANIES CAME TO US OF
THEIR OWN VOLITION. THEY CAME
BECAUSE GOVERNMENT TOOK ACTION
BECAUSE YOU HELD HEARINGS
BECAUSE YOU PROPOSED REGULATION
AND LEGISLATION.
AND WE NEED THAT SORT OF ACTION
WE NEED LEADERSHIP.
IF YOU DON'T A THE OTHER
PANELISTS TALKED ABOUT THIS
COULD GO A VERY DIFFERENT
DIRECTION AND LET ME TALK
BRIEFLY ABOUT THAT OTHER
SCENARIO.
THE INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVES MY
GAS ARE GONNA COME UP HERE AND
TALK ABOUT.
AVOIDING REGULATION.
SO LET'S GO BACK TO THE DE. OF
TRACKING IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
BEFORE THAT IT WAS A MIDDLE
CLASS JOB THERE WERE SONGS ON
THE RADIO WE SAW SMOKEY AND THE
BANDIT IN THE MOVIE THEATERS
HERE NOW.
AFTER DEREGULATION AND THIS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR MODEL
ROSE OUT OF THE ASHES THAT WAS
TALKED ABOUT.
LOUDTHE TRUCKING COMPANIES TO
OUTSOURCE.
ALL THE COSTS AND RISKS OF
TRUCKING ON THE BACKS OF THE
WORKERS.
AND OF COURSE AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR IS TREATED AS A SMALL
BUSINESS UNDER THE LAW AND CAN
ORGANIZE A UNION.
IN SHORT TIME TRUCKING WENT TO A
JOB WHERE PEOPLE ARE WORKING
SIXTY SEVENTY EIGHTY HOURS A
WEEK. WITH NO BENEFITS NO SOCIAL
SECURITY NO WORKERS COMP NO
NOTHING MAKING LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE.
DOES THAT SOUND FAMILIAR.
THIS IS THE UBER AND LEFT MODEL.
THERE'S NOTHING NEW ABOUT THIS
THERE'S NOTHING INNOVATIVE THE
ONLY THING THAT'S NEW IS THE
TECHNOLOGY.
AND SHORT OF BOLD ACTION ON YOUR
PART THIS IS THE FUTURE OF WORK.
AS IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT THEIR
MAYBE ACTUALLY NET NEW JOBS IN
IN LOGISTICS WORK AND SUPPLY
CHAIN.
.
DESPITE AUTOMATION DESPITE THE
AMAZON A FACT.
BUT IF YOU DON'T TAKE ACTION.
THESE COULD BE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR JOBS AND PEOPLE.
DOING GIGS.
THAT MAY ACTUALLY BE THE REAL
APOCALYPSE AN ECONOMY THAT FAILS
TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE.
SO LAST THING. WHAT SHOULD YOU
BE DOING?
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME GETS
TOSSED AROUND A LOT.
IT SOUNDS NICE BUT WHO PAYS FOR.
PORTABLE BENEFITS.
INTERESTING IDEA BUT NOT ALLOWS
EMPLOYERS TO MISS CLASSIFY THEIR
WORKERS AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND AVOID PAYING
INTO EXISTING SOCIAL SAFETY
NETS.
RETRAINING.
WE SHOULD HAVE ANOTHER HEARING
ON THE FAILURES OF RETRAINING
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO FIX
THAT.
I WOULD SUGGEST IT'S TIME TO GO
BIG.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY NINE AMERICAN
WORKERS HAD FULL EMPLOYMENT
UNEMPLOYMENT WAS AT THREE POINT
TWO PERCENT.
BY NINETEEN THIRTY THREE WALL
STREET HAD PLUNGE THE COUNTRY
INTO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
UNEMPLOYMENT FIFTEEN MILLION
WORKERS WERE OUT ON THE STREETS.
GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE WAS NOT TO
BAIL OUT WALL STREET BECAUSE
THEY WERE TOO BIG TO FAIL.
GOVERNMENT BAILED OUT THE REST
OF US.
THEY PASSED THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ACT IN NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE DAY
PASSED THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT. AND THEY SAID.
THEY NEEDED TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF EMPLOYEES AND
EMPLOYERS TO ENCOURAGE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND TO
CURTAIL CERTAIN PRIVATE SECTOR
LABOR AND MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
WHICH CAN HARM. THE GENERAL
WELFARE OF WORKERS BUSINESSES IN
THE ECONOMY.
THAT WOULD SOUND RADICAL IN
TODAY'S CONGRESS.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT THEY
PASSED THE FAIR LABOR STANDARDS
ACT.
OVERTIME EIGHT HOUR DAY NO CHILD
LABOR MINIMUM WAGE.
IT'S TIME TO GO BIG. THAT'S THE
REAL INNOVATION THAT WE NEED
FROM YOU AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WAS FAIRLY.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMOND.
MISTER PAN.
AGAIN I I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAKING FREDDIE
ON THIS AND I WOULD CONCUR WITH
MY.
BROTHER DOT BLOT THAT I AM
DISAPPOINTED IN THE OTHER
MEMBERS THAT HAVE NOT SHOWN UP
OR SHOWN INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE
BUT I THINK YOU VERY MUCH AND
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ON THESE ISSUES AYE. OUTSIDE OF
GLOBAL WARMING AND CLIMATE
CHANGE I THINK THIS IS THE
CRITICAL QUESTION OF OUR TIME
ABOUT WHAT IS THE FUTURE WORK
LOOK LIKE.
IT WORKERS.
I'M WORKERS DO NOT WANT A
HANDOUT THERE'S DIGNITY AND WORK
THERE IS MEANING IN WORK AND
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE TO CREATE THAT
DIGNITY MEANING. I THINK THERE
ARE TWO QUESTIONS
AS WE THINK ABOUT THESE BIG BIG
ISSUES NUMBER ONE IS THE
QUESTION AROUND TECHNOLOGIES
IMPACT ON OUR WORK.
I WANNA TALK WITHOUT A SECOND
BUT I THINK THERE'S ANOTHER
PIECE OF THIS ESPECIALLY WHERE
GOVERNMENT PLAYS A BIG ROLE. AND
THAT IS THE ACTUAL UNDERLYING
ECONOMIC STRUCTURE THAT DRIVES
THAT DRIVES HIS DECISIONS. IF
YOU LOOK AT OUR INDUSTRY IN THE
YOU SCW WE REPRESENT RETAIL
WHERE THE RETAIL CLERKS UNION ME
CUTTERS IN FOOD PROCESSING WE
REPRESENT A LOT OF WORKERS IN
THE RETAIL SPACE.
AND A LOT OF THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS IN OUR IN OUR SECTOR
ARE OWNED BY PRIVATE EQUITY
COMPANIES.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
FORTY THREE LARGE RETAIL
SUPERMARKET COMPANIES WHICH
OWNED TEN OR MORE STORES HAVE
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY IN UNITED
STATES. AND EIGHTEEN OF THOSE
COMPANIES ARE OWNED BY PRIVATE
EQUITY.
YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT YOU KNOW
THE MOST RECENT EXAMPLE IS TOYS
R. US EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT
TOYS R. US.
TOYS R. US WITH THEIR EIGHT
HUNDRED STORES AND THIRTY
THOUSAND WORKERS ARE GONNA BE
OUT OF A JOB THE STORES IN A
CLOSE.
AND SURE AMAZON AND OTHER ONLINE
RETAILERS HAVE CREATED
COMPETITION. BUT REALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE UNDERLYING
PIECE OF THIS IS THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE COMPANIES ARE OWNED BY
PRIVATE EQUITY LIKE BAIN CAPITAL
WHO GET LOADED WITH DEBT AND
THEN CAN'T PY CAN'T PAY OFF.
THE INTEREST ON THE DEBT NOT WE
HAVE TO DECLARE BANKRUPTCY AND
WHAT HAPPENS IN THAT BANKRUPTCY.
WHO ACTUALLY GETS PAID THE
WORKERS WITHOUT JOBS IN THE LEFT
WITH LITTLE TO NOTHING IN THE
SHAREHOLDERS GET MADE WHOLE?
WHEN THEY SAW THE ASSETS THIS IS
ANOTHER MAJOR PIECE OF JUST
WHAT'S DRIVING THIS THIS
CONVERSATION IS YOU HAVE
COMPANIES LIKE AMAZON WHO ARE
ACTUALLY. REINVESTING IN THEIR
COMPANY NOT TAKING ASSETS OUT
EXTRACTING ACCESO BUT ACTUALLY
PUTTING ASSETS BACK INTO CREE
LARGER VALUE AND THE
CAPITALIZING ON THE LOSS OF
BRICK AND MORTAR TAKE TO OPEN UP
THAT SPACE IN RETAIL SO I
BELIEVE. THAT'S ANOTHER LARGE
QUESTION THAT'S NOT THE SUBJECT
OF THIS HEARING BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY WE HAVE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO. IS THE
UNDERLYING ECONOMIC STRUCTURE
THAT WE'RE CREATING IN THIS IN
THIS COUNTRY AND IN THE WORLD.
AND I THINK BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE STATE GOVERNMENT
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE A
REAL ROLE TO PLAY IN TERMS OF
CREATING DISINCENTIVES. AROUND
THIS RESTRUCTURING AND
ULTIMATELY UNDERMINES OUR
ABILITY TO CREATE WORK.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF
THAT QUESTION ABOUT WHAT'S THE
IMPACT OF TECHNOLOGY IN OUR. IN
OUR SECTORS I WILL TELL YOU
THAT.
YOU KNOW WE JUST REITERATE WHAT
WAS SAID HERE THAT WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
EMBRACE THIS CHANGE AND ACTUALLY
CAPITALIZE ON THE POWER OF THE
WORK FORCE. TO MAKE THIS
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE AND
INNOVATION WORK FOR WORKERS WORK
FOR SOCIETY. YOU KNOW ONLY A
STUDY BY MCKINSEY.
I CAME OUT WHERE IT SAID SIXTY
PERCENT OF JOBS
SIX PERCENT OF JOBS CAN HAVE AT
LEAST THIRTY PERCENT OF THEIR
WORK AUTOMATED.
SO THINK ABOUT THAT SO IT'S NOT
AS MASSIVE AS A HUNDRED PERCENT
BUT SIXTY PERCENT OF THOSE JOBS
CAN HAVE THIRTY PERCENT OF THEIR
WORK AUTOMATED. AND I THINK A
PART OF THIS A REAL BIG PART OF
THIS IS. WHEN YOU WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT OUR ACTUAL UNDERLYING
EDUCATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE LOOKS
LIKE. YOU KNOW AND IN WHILE.
I BELIEVE THE WAY THAT WE
ULTIMATELY TRAIN WORKERS AND DO
THIS IN AND CREATE A TRANSITION
IN THIS ECONOMY. IS GONNA BE KEY
TO HOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE WORKERS
BE ABLE TO. TO CONTINUE TO DO
THE JOBS NECESSARY AND ACTUALLY
CREATE VALUE FOR COMPANIES AND
VALUE FOR CONSUMERS IN A WAY
THAT NO ONE ELSE CAN.
AND YOU KNOW WE GET AS WE INVEST
IN THAT WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN ALSO EMPOWER WORKERS
AND THAT THAT WAS EXAMPLES.
GIVEN EARLIER ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN GERMANY. THE MOST
RECENT EXAMPLE IS BETWEEN THE
GERMAN GOVERNMENT THE GERMAN
STEEL WORKERS UNION AND THE
GERMAN STEEL INDUSTRY WHERE THEY
WILL TO NEGOTIATE CHANGES.
AROUND THEIR WORKING CONDITIONS
WHERE YOU KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT
THE EIGHT HOUR DAY WILL THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN RESTRUCTURING.
A DATA MAY YOU BE LESS THAN AN
EIGHT HOUR DAY FOR THE SAME PAY
IN GERMANY THEY REDUCE THE WITH
THE DAY FROM A WEEK FROM THIRTY
SIX HOURS A WEEK TO TWENTY EIGHT
HOURS A WEEK. AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE ABLE TO GET A FOUR PERCENT
INCREASE IN THEIR SALARY IN PAY.
AND ALSO REINVESTED IN AND
TRAINING AND FACILITATION OF
GOING TO OTHER CAREERS AS
TECHNOLOGY IMPACTS THAT
WORKFORCE I THINK THOSE ARE SOME
IDEAS WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IN
TERMS OF.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IN TERMS OF
OUR ABILITY TO. TO.
THINK ABOUT THAT AS WE MOVE
AHEAD IN THIS STRUCTURE. AND I
WILL SAY THE FINAL THING IS YOU
KNOW AMAZON GO BLUE APRON SELF
CHECKOUT APPLE PAY AND MANY
OTHER ADVANCES IN TECHNOLOGY
WILL CHANGE THE RETAIL
LANDSCAPE.
BUT WILL NOT WHAT WILL NOT
CHANGE IS THAT EMPLOYERS THAT
CAN CREATE AN EXPERIENCE THAT
ATTRACTS PEOPLE TO THE BRICK AND
MORTAR. BRICK AND MORTAR
LOCATIONS THE OPPORTUNITY
RETRAIN WORKERS TO GAIN SOFT
SKILLS IN CUSTOMER SERVICE AS
WELL AS HARD SKILLS. LIKE
EXPANDING CULINARY TRAINING TO
THE RETAIL SITES WILL BE OF
VALUE ADDED.
THE CURRENT BANKRUPTCY OF TOYS
R. US IS JUST THE LATEST
EXAMPLE.
WELL ONLINE RETAILERS IS AMAZON
GO GROUPON AND OTHERS HAVE
PROVIDED COMPETITION BRICK AND
MORTAR. AGAIN I BELIEVE PRIVATE
EQUITIES ADVANCEMENTS THAT
RESELL SECTOR HAS REALLY
EXACERBATED THE PROBLEM.
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO A BETTER
JOB AT REGULATING WALL STREET
CREATING MORE EQUITABLE TAX
STRUCTURE INCENTIVIZING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LABOR TO
DEVELOP A TRAINING. FOR THE
GREAT TRANSITION THAT IS
HAPPENING OUR ECONOMY TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEIR PROFESSIONS
AND BY EXTENSION FOR CONSUMERS
TO CONSUME THE GOODS. THAT
WORKERS AND COMPANIES ARE
PRODUCING I'M GLAD THAT WE LIVE
IN A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE CHAIRS SUCH AS SENATOR AND
IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMOND TO
REALLY HELP LEAD IN THIS
CONVERSATION. AND YOU HAVE OUR
COMMITMENT UFCW IN THE THE
WRESTLE LABOR COMMUNITY AS YOU
CAN SEE HERE COMMITMENT TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNMENT AND ALSO
WORK WITH OUR EMPLOYERS. TO MAKE
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY PAY FOR
WORKERS AND SOCIETY THAT WE LIVE
IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER IRVING AND I'M
SORE.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY THANK YOU
T. OR ON BEHALF OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS
STATEWIDE AND I REALLY. WANT TO
TRY TO GIVE A PERSPECTIVE ON THE
THE PUBLIC SECTOR IMPACT OF
AUTOMATION I THINK WE OFTEN
THINK ABOUT AUTOMATION I THINK
ABOUT THE PRIVATE SECTOR I THINK
MY BROTHERS HAVE GIVEN. A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF OF THE FEAR AND THAT
THE COMPLEXITIES ON THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SIDE BUT ON THE PUBLIC
SECTOR SIDE.
THIS FEAR OF AUTOMATION AND HAS
REALLY TAKEN US BY STORM WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED IN IT FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS SO I HOPE TO GIVE YOU
GUYS SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW IT HAS
WORK TO OUR BENEFIT. BUT THEN
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE
LEERY ABOUT ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SAFETY NET
BENEFITS THAT I KNOW YOU TWO IN
PARTICULAR CARE DEEPLY ABOUT.
AND HOW AUTOMATION EFFECTS THAT
AFFECTS THE SERVICE DELIVERY.
I'M I THINK IF YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT.
OUR APPREHENSION ON INNOVATION
IT'S BECAUSE THAT A LOT OF IT IS
BASED ON COST SAVINGS AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT COST SAVINGS A
VENDOR WANTING TO COME TO A
PUBLIC AGENCY AND TALK ABOUT
COST SAVINGS IN THE SENSE OF OUR
SAFETY NET BENEFITS. THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A FEAR THAT GOES WITH
IT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
INNOVATION THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT I THINK THAT OUR
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES WANT
TO BE PART OF AN INNOVATION
STRATEGY AND A STRATEGY TO TRY
TO MAKE BENEFITS AND SERVICE
DELIVERY. MORE ACHIEVABLE AND
MORE CONVENIENT FOR THE CLIENTS
THAT WE SERVE BUT NOT FOR THE
PURPOSES SOLELY OF COST SAVINGS
WHICH I THINK HAS BEEN THE
PARAMOUNT OF A LOT OF THE
VENDORS THAT HAVE SHOPPED AROUND
THE CAPITAL. FOR YEAR OVER YEAR
SPECIFICALLY FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR
MEDI CAL PROGRAM YOU GUYS KNOW
THAT WE EXPANDED MEDI CAL SOME
YEARS AGO WHEN THERE WAS AN
ATTEMPT WHEN THAT ANSETT
HAPPENED THEY WOULD BE
PRIVATIZING IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE CAN APPLY
THROUGH. THERE ITEM THERE'S
THEIR PHONES IN THEIR COMPUTERS
AT HOME AND THAT'S NOT THE
REALITY OF THE SAFETY NET
BENEFITS THAT WE PROVIDE
UNFORTUNATELY IT ROLLED OUT
PRETTY FAST AND YOU GUYS WERE
VERY PARAMOUNT IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE. THIS IDEA
OF AUTOMATION WAS KIND OF THE
PARAMOUNT IDEA OF HOW THESE
FOLKS WE GET SERVICE DELIVERY IT
WASN'T UNTIL AFTER IT DIDN'T
WORK FOR SOME TIME THAT WORKERS
BECAME FRIGHTENED CENTER IN THAT
CONVERSATION. THAT WORKERS WERE
AT THE FRONT LINES OF HOW
INNOVATION WORKS AND HOW THAT'S
DIFFERENT FROM A COST SAVINGS
OUR GOAL IN MENTALITY THAT WE
THINK DROVE A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION BEFORE. THE
DIFFERENCE AND THAT IS WHEN THE
WORKERS GOT INVOLVED WE ACTUALLY
GAVE INPUT ON WHAT ALGORITHMS
ACTUALLY WORK TO GET PEOPLE
TRANSITION VARIOUS IT
SEE IF THE COMPUTER SYSTEMS WILL
LOCK UP. IF THE SYSTEMS WHEN
ACTUALLY WORK BECAUSE AT THE END
WHEN SOMETHING IN THE AUTOMATION
DOESN'T WORK ESPECIALLY FOR
SAFETY NET BENEFITS THEY COME TO
THE IN PERSON WORKER AT SOME
POINT TIME. AND THEY'RE VERY
FRUSTRATED AND THEY'VE BEEN
THROUGH A LONG PROCESS OF BEING
ON A PHONE CALL PRESSING ONE
PRESSING TO PRESSING THREE GOING
BACK TO ONE AND THEY CAN'T GET
WHAT THEY NEED. AS A BY THE TIME
THEY'RE IN THE FACE OF OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS ARE STATE WORKERS AT
EDIE DEAR DIEM V. THEY ARE
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED. RIGHT OUR
JOB AS SOCIAL SERVICE WORKERS IN
PUBLIC SERVICE WORKERS ARTIST
SERVICE THE CLIENT IT'S
COMPLETELY CONTRARY TO A PUBLIC.
MISSION OF PROFIT SAVINGS ARE
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO SAVE
MONEY IT'S IT COMPLETELY GOES
CONTRADICTORY TO THAT AND I
THINK OUR GOAL AS FRONTLINE
WORKERS ON YOUR BEHALF IS TO
HELP THE CLIENTS. DELIVER
SERVICES AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE STATE OF MIND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT OUR SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS IT'S A SAFETY NET IT'S
THE NET THAT'S GONNA CATCH
PEOPLE AND THE MOST VULNERABLE
TIMES. IN THE RULES VULNERABLE
TIMES OF NEED WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE DON'T FOLLOW THOSE
CRACKS. HAVING A SYSTEM THAT IS
PUT IN PLACE ONLY TO SAVE MONEY
IS.
BY FAR GONNA HAVE MORE CRACKS IN
IT THAN A HUMAN BEING CAN HAVE
OFTENTIMES ARE GONNA COME AND
SAY WE WANT TO INNOVATE WE WANT
TO STREAMLINE AND OUR MINDS
THOSE ARE WAYS. TO TAKE AWAY
JOBS OF THE PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS THAT YOU GUYS HAVE THAT
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES EVERY
SINGLE DAY TO DO THIS WORK.
I AM I THINK THAT IF WE I TALK
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
AUTOMATION HAPPENS WITHOUT THE
WORKERS INPUT. WE LOSE WORKERS
ON THE FRONT LINES THOSE ARE
GOOD PAYING JOBS THAT WORKERS
LOSE OFTENTIMES ALL SAME WORKERS
ARE IN THE SAME LINES OF THE
SAME PEOPLE THEY ARE PROTECTING.
BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE OUT OF A JOB
AND THEY NEED SERVICES FROM OUR
SAFETY NET BENEFITS TRAINING IS
ESSENTIAL. WORKERS HAVE TO KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE EXPECTED TO DO HOW
THE SYSTEMS WORK A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT ROLLED OUT A MEDI
CAL HAPPENED WITHOUT WORKERS
BEING TRAINED AND SO WORKERS
THAT KNOW. HOW TO ANSWER A LOT
OF THE QUESTIONS ONCE THEY
ROLLED OUT?
IF WE ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN IT WOULD INNOVATION
OR A COST SAVINGS MEASURES ARE
PUT IN PLACE FOR AUTOMATION THAT
ACTUALLY GOES CONTRARY TO THE
ULTIMATE GOAL. AND A LOT OF THE
SYSTEMS WERE AUTOMATION WAS PUT
FORWARD IN THE STATE CHILD
SUPPORT THE COURT SYSTEMS THE M.
V. ET DE LA CALLE HERE'S PROJECT
I CAN GO ON FOR EVER. THEY ENDED
UP COSTING THE STATE MORE MONEY
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE COST IF WE
WOULD JUST INVESTED IN FRONTLINE
WORKERS BECAUSE PROCUREMENT HAS
TO HAPPEN. THE SYSTEMS DON'T
WORK CLIENTS COME TO THE TABLE
AND SAY I'M NOT GETTING MY
BENEFITS ON TIME AND YOU HAVE A
FEDERAL LAWSUIT FACING YOU
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CERTAIN TIME
LIMIT. TO DELIVER A TO PEOPLE
THAT WE CARE ABOUT.
UNFORTUNATELY ISN'T THAT NEW
AUTOMATION IN THE WORLD OF
PUBLIC SERVICES ISN'T
NECESSARILY A NEW THING THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCE IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE ENGAGED IN
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND THE TIME THAT
IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL HAS BEEN
WHEN THE WORKERS ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE. WHEN THE WORKERS ARE
ACTUALLY TELLING THEIR
EXPERIENCE THAT I HEARD MY
BROTHER'S TALK ABOUT TWO IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CAN TELL THEIR
EXPERIENCE OF WHAT'S EFFECTIVE
AND WHAT'S NOT EFFECTIVE ABSENT
THAT. THE GOAL IS NOT INNOVATION
THE GOAL AGAIN GOES BACK TO THE
PROFIT SAVINGS AND THE COST
SAVINGS THAT AGAIN IS COMPLETELY
CONTRARY TO THE DELIVERY OF
PUBLIC SECTOR SERVICES. FOR OUR
SAFETY NET IN MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. I THINK IF YOU ASK
WHAT THE STATE CAN DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTROLLED
AUTOMATION AND THE IDEA OF
INNOVATION ON OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
SERVICES IN OUR SAFETY NET
BENEFITS IS AGAIN. I HATE TO BE
REDUNDANT WORKERS HAVE TO LEAD
WE HAVE TO BE ON THE FRONT LINES
OF THE DISCUSSION WE KNOW FIRST
HAND HOW TO MAKE.
APPLYING FOR SERVICES MORE
CONVENIENT FOR WORK FOR CLIENTS
BECAUSE WERE THERE AND WE SEE IT
A CAN BE BASED ON AN ALGORITHM
ARE A SYSTEM THAT IS INTENDED
ONLY TO SAVE COSTS THAT'S NOT
INNOVATION THAT AGAIN. IT'S ALL
AS ALL I PIVOTED AT A COST
SAVINGS AND OF COST SAVINGS IS
THE MOTIVATION THAT WE HAVE TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
IMPACTS TO PUBLIC SERVICES.
CLIENTS ARE GONNA FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS BECAUSE THE GOAL IN
COST SAVINGS.
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN ACHIEVE IT
IS BY GIVING CLIENTS LESS
BENEFITS.
THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE IS TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF WORKERS
THAT ARE ON THE FRONT LINES.
AND I THINK IN BOTH OF THOSE
INSTANCES YOU GUYS WERE HERE HOW
CONTRADICTORY IDEAS TO THE GOAL
OF PUBLIC SERVICE WE WANT TO
CATCH EVERYBODY BEFORE THEY FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS. WE WANT TO
TRY TO PROVIDE SELF SUFFICIENCY
IN EVERY WAY THAT WE CAN THERE
IS NO ALGORITHM THAT CAN TELL US
A PERSON THAT CAME IN FOR CAL
FRESH ACTUALLY NEED HOUSING.
THERE'S NO ALGORITHM THAT CAN
TELL US SOMEBODY THAT CAME IN
FOR HOUSING ACTUALLY MIGHT NEED
A MEDI CAL CARD. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HUMAN BEINGS SEE
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE SEE
THROUGH OUR DIALOGUE THAT OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM THERE IS
A REALITY THAT THERE ARE THOSE
WHO MEET THE HAPPY PATH THAT YOU
PROBABLY HEAR ABOUT A LOT IN
YOUR. SUB COMMITTEES AND YOU
HEAR ABOUT A LOT AS WELL THERE'S
SOME INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA
THEY CAN GO THROUGH AN
ELIGIBILITY PROCESS OR PROCESS.
TO THEIR PHONE ARE DOING ON MY
SYSTEM THAT IS HAPPY THERE'S NO
HICCUPS IS VERY RARE AND IT'S
NOT COMMON AND SO IN THOSE
INSTANCES THEY HAVE TO REACH OUT
TO WORKER THEY HAVE TO CONTACT A
WORKER. IN OF THE WORKER ISN'T
FAMILIAR AND LEADING THE
ALGORITHM IN THE SYSTEMS THAT
THE CLIENT JUST WENT THROUGH WE
HAVE TO TELL A WORKER I CAN'T
HELP YOU. OUR CLIENT I'M SORRY
THAT WE CAN HELP YOU AND THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS IS IS EASY
FOR A CLIENT TO ACCEPT WHEN
THEY'RE IN THEIR MOST VULNERABLE
STATE AND THEY'RE SEEKING HELP
AND THE MOST VULNERABLE STATE OF
MIND. SO I WOULD SAY THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO AS AS
THE ELECTED OFFICIALS AT US ON
THE LABOR SIDE IS WORK TOGETHER
WHEN AUTOMATION COMES ESPECIALLY
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR. AND
SECONDLY BE ABLE TO CALL A DUCK
A DUCK IF THERE IS A GOOD HAVE
THERE'S A GOAL OF COST SAVINGS
WHAT'S THE IMPACT AND AT WHAT
COST. NOT ONLY FROM THE WORKERS
PERSPECTIVE AND PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS LOSING THEIR JOB BUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO THE
CLIENT THAT WANTED TO COME IN
AND RECEIVE HORIZONTAL
INTEGRATION OF SERVICES THAT YOU
GUYS ARE VERY AWARE OF AS WELL.
AND ONLY RECEIVE ONE SERVICE
BECAUSE THEY WENT THEY WENT
ONLINE SYSTEM I THINK SEIU IS
FULLY COMMITTED TO TRYING TO
INNOVATE AND TRYING TO MAKE
THINGS EASIER FOR CLIENTS BUT
NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. AND
CERTAINLY NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF
GOOD PUBLIC SECTOR JOBS.
OF THANK YOU SO MUCH AND.
NOTE STATE THEY HAVE TO
ACTUALLY HAVE A MIXED RECORD
ACTUALLY WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
SUCCESSFUL IT PROJECTS ATTENDED
YOUR LOSS ABOUT THOSE IN THE
NEWS AND WE'VE HAD SEVERAL THAT
HAVE BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL IN.
I'VE ALWAYS MARK THAT THE.
ONES IN WHICH THEY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IS OFTEN ARE THE ONES
WHERE THE VENDOR COMES IN AND
SAYS I HAVE A SOLUTION AND
DOESN'T TALK TO THE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK.
AND THEY HAVE IN THEIR MINDS
SOME. SOMETHING THEY IMAGINED
ABOUT HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO WORK
IN THE NEXT TALK PEOPLE DOING
THE WORK AND THEN THEY WONDER
WHY SYSTEM DOESN'T WORK VERY
WELL. AND THAT WHY EVERYONE'S
FRUSTRATED WITH IT SO.
.
SO CERTAINLY I THINK THAT
THAT'S. WHEN WE LOOK AT. HOW WE
AUTOMATE IT ELEVATES?
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT ASPECT.
BUT IT IT YOU THINK THE OTHER
PIECE THOUGH IS THAT I'D LIKE TO
ASK YOU ABOUT IS.
IT IS IT WAS BROUGHT UP IS THAT.
.
THE IDEA THAT.
THAT ACTUALLY.
INNOVATION AUTOMATION CARE AND
ACTUALLY IMPROVES THE.
THE PRODUCTIVITY OF THE WORKER
THERE'S AN ADVANTAGE THERE.
I THINK THERE IS A PART ABOUT
THAT IMPROVE PROGRAM FACT WE'VE
SEEN OVER TIME THAT. WE'VE HAD
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY BY
WORKERS.
SOME DO THAT AUTOMATION SOME
DUE TO OTHER FACTORS OVER THE
PAST COUPLE DECADES.
BUT THE ACTUAL REWARDS OF THAT
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY HAS NOT
BEEN SHARED WITH THE WORKER IT'S
GOT OFF TO WALLSTREET OR
WHEREVER ELSE.
AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO AS WERE
WORKING ON.
IMPROVING PRODUCTIVITY TO BE
ENSURING THAT.
THE WORKERS ACTUALLY GET A FAIR
SHARE OF THE PRODUCTIVITY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT DATA RESULTING
AND HOW TO ENSURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS IS WERE MOVING AHEAD
WITH. WITH THE.
INNOVATION AUTOMATION LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE CALL IT'S.
SO PERHAPS WE CAN.
TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ON WHAT YOU
SEE IS AS YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
PRIVATE SECTOR PUBLIC SECTOR
PEOPLE SAY.
AND SAY THAT OKAY WE WANT TO END
OF AB ONE AUTOMATE BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO.
YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT THAT'S
ALLOW YEAR.
MEMBERS OF THE WORKERS TO BE
ABLE TO DO A LITTLE MORE THAN
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO BEFORE
MAYBE DO MORE EASILY ETCETERA.
.
HOW THE CONVERSATIONS GO ABOUT
OKAY GREAT NOW YOU GET TO WE
WERE DOING A LITTLE LAWYER AND?
PROBABLY HOPEFULLY YOU MAKE A
LOT MORE MONEY AND WHAT PART OF
IT'S COMING BACK TO THE PERSON
IS ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK.
BEGIN WITH. SO I I THINK IN
PUBLIC SERVICES THERE'S A NUMBER
OF EXAMPLES WHERE AUTOMATION HAS
WORKED AND HELPED OUR
PRODUCTIVITY. THAT FOR EXAMPLE
IN CAL WORKS WE USED TO REQUIRE
PAGE AT STEPS TO BE BROUGHT INTO
THE OFFICE WEEZER REQUIRE THEIR
WHOLE BANKING STATEMENT TO BE
BROUGHT INTO THE OFFICE. THAT
CAN BE ELECTRONICALLY SCANNED
AND SENT TO A WORKER RIGHT SO IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE WORKER TO
LEAVE HER DESK AND GO TO THE
LOBBY COLLECT INFORMATION PUT IT
IN A HARD FILE. THOSE THINGS DO
IMPROVE PRODUCTIVITY BUT ALL OF
THOSE THINGS IN THERE'S A NUMBER
OF EXAMPLES LIKE THAT WERE DONE
WITH THE WORKER INPUT SO IT GOES
BACK TO I THINK WHERE WE STARTED
THE CONVERSATION IF THE WORKER
IS SITTING DOWN. AND THERE'S A
QUESTION HOW DO WE INNOVATE HOW
DO WE IMPROVE PRODUCTIVITY TO
HELP YOU DO YOUR JOB BETTER
RIGHT THRE'S A NUMBER OF IDEAS
THAT OUR MEMBERS CAN COME UP
WITH THAT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A
LOT OF THEM WITH OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH YOU IN THE
COUNTIES AND SUCH. I THINK THAT
THE PROBLEMS COME AS WHICH WHICH
YOU SAID WHEN THEY HAPPEN BEFORE
THERE'S ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
WORKER WITH AN ANTICIPATION THAT
I THINK THIS MIGHT HELP. AND
REALLY IT ACTUALLY PILES ONTO
THE NUMBER AND THE AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT WE HAVE TO DO SO HOW I
THINK WERE INNOVATIVE WERE
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO SOLVE IT
BUT IF A VENDOR IS LEADING THE
CONVERSATION AND THE WORKERS ARE
ONLY IN THE CONVERSATION YOU'RE
STARTING OUT. FROM THE WRONG
BLOCK IN YOU KNOW IN WHAT I IS
SO AND THE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THAT THIS TWO
PIECES OF THIS.
NUMBER ONE IS WE CANNOT ALLOW
EMPLOYERS TO REROUTE TO REWRITE
THE RULES AROUND WHO WHO WHO
THEY WORK FOR.
RIGHT WE HAVE TO CREATE A EQUAL
LEVEL ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS THE
INDUSTRIES TO HAVE REAL FAIR
COMPETITION RIGHT BECAUSE OF
SOME WORK SO IN OUR WORLD.
IF SOME OF THE EMPLOYERS THAT WE
REPRESENT ACTUALLY HAVE
EMPLOYEES AND THEY'RE IN THERE
AND THEY'RE BOUND BY A SERIES OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE LOGGED
A ONE THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. AND YOU HAVE OTHER
EMPLOYERS THAT DON'T HAVE
EMPLOYEES AND SUBCONTRACT OUT
THERE WORKING ON IT.
UNACCOUNTABLE TO THE SAME LEVELS
OF NEW LAW THAT THE THAT THE
EMPLOYERS WE REPRESENT OUR THAN
THAT RIGHT THERE WAS UNFAIR
MARKETPLACE UNFAIR COMPETITION.
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY ABOUT
CREATING A FAIR PLAYING FIELD
AROUND COMPETITION FOR REALLY
GONNA HAVE A TRUE FREE MARKET
RIGHT. I WOULD SAY SECONDLY.
.
YEAH I I LOOK BACK TO THAT IT
WAS TWO THOUSAND TEN A TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN OUR BARACK
OBAMA GOTTEN REALLY CRITICIZED
HE SAID YOU DIDN'T BUILD THAT.
RIGHT YOU KNOW HE CAME THAT
VISALIA RALLY IN IT WAS THE SAME
THAT YOU CAN BILL THAT WHAT HE
WAS. NO WE ALL BELOW KNOWN
BELIEVES. HIS ACTIONS ARE ABOUT
HOW.
NO COMPANY EXISTS AN ISLAND NO
INNOVATION HAPPENS WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT OF AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY
IT'S REALLY ABOUT HOW DO WE USE
THAT LEVERAGE IN THIS TRANSITION
TO SAY YOU'RE GONNA BE A COMBO
OF WE INVEST DOLLARS IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION. WHEN WE INVEST
DOLLARS IN SORT OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT YOU
COMPANY ARE BENEFITING FROM THAT
YOU HAVE WE HAVE TO HAVE A
COMMITMENT BACK FROM YOU. THAT
YOU DON'T OF REINVEST THAT YOUR
WORK FORCE RIGHT AND I THINK
THERE'S WAYS TO DO THAT. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS WE HAVE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARD DOLLARS WE HAVE
YOU KNOW A SERIES OF DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TRINITY COLLEGE
WITH A SERIES OF DIFFERENT
THINGS AS.
AS EMPLOYES ARE GOING ON HIRING
PEOPLE THEY'RE GETTING THE
BENEFIT OF THIS EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM I THINK IS A TIME TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE RESTRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW THESE CONCEPTS AROUND
JOB RETRAINING IN JUST YOU KNOW
JOB BECAUSE HE'S IN A WAY THAT
CREATES A LEVERAGE POINT. FOR
WORKERS IN A LEVERAGE POINT FOR
YOU KNOW THE STATE AND I THINK
THOSE THINGS TO DO AND GET AND
AND REALLY BUILD A TRUE
PARTNERSHIP.
TO BE IN BUSINESS AND LABOR AND
GOVERNMENT.
I'M A TEAMSTER SO I WON'T PULL
ANY PUNCHES.
EVERY EMPLOYER THAT WE'VE DEALT
WITH THAT'S DOING THIS
TECHNOLOGY. TOM PAUL OF OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH SILICON VALLEY.
IS THAT EVERYBODY'S VERY NERVOUS
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN TERMS
OF REGULATION.
WE STILL LIVE IN A DAY AND AGE
WHERE LABOR HAS CONSIDERABLE
POLITICAL POWER IN THIS
BUILDING.
AND AT THE LEVEL OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND WE WORK VERY HARD TO MAKE
THAT A REALITY.
SO WE HAVE SOME EMPLOYERS WHO I
WOULD.
SAY ARE ENLIGHTENED ENOUGH TO
RECOGNIZE.
THAT.
THERE BENEFITS IN A PARTNERSHIP.
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY SHAPE
REGULATIONS THAT HELP THEM DO
THE INNOVATION THAT THEY WANTED
TO?
AND HELP US MAKE SURE THAT OUR
MEMBERS ARE BENEFICIARIES OF
THAT INNOVATION AS WELL.
WE CAN EAT DINNER FOR NOT
INVITED TO THE PARTY.
SO EVERYTIME YOU HOLD ONE OF
THESE HEARINGS AND PEOPLE LIKE
US GET INVITED TO COME UP AND
TESTIFY.
I WALK OUT HERE WITH FIVE
BUSINESS CARDS FROM SOME COMPANY
THAT'S DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY
THAT WANTS TO TALK TO US.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED YOUR HELP
AND AND.
I WANT TO REDO A HEADLINE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA FELL CHAU.
LABOR FEDERATION THE STATE FEDS
NEWSLETTER.
TALKING ABOUT AN AUTOMATION
CONFERENCE CALL BY GOVERNOR
BROWN.
GOVERNOR BROWN ANNOUNCED THIS
THURSDAY HE IS CALLED THE
STATEWIDE CONFERENCE OF BUSINESS
AND LABOR LEADERS TO DISCUSS THE
IMPACT OF AUTOMATION ON
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS AND THE
ECONOMY.
CONFERENCE WILL BE HELD ON LA ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH AND
TWENTY EIGHTH
WITH ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
REPRESENTATIVES OF LABOR
INDUSTRY EDUCATION IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. SO WHEN I FIRST
HEARD ABOUT THIS I WAS SAYING
HEY HOW COME WE DIDN'T GET AN
INVITATION TO THIS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA ON THIS
IT'S SEPTEMBER EIGHTH NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE.
IT WAS ARE CURRENT GOVERNOR'S.
FATHER I WANT TO THANK SARAH
FLOCKS FROM THE STATE FED FOR
THIS. WE NEED THE SAME SORT OF
GOVERNMENT CONVENING WE NEED A
COMMISSION TO LOOK AT THESE
ISSUES ON AUTOMATION TECHNOLOGY
IN THE FUTURE OF WORK. WE NEED
YOU TO SET THE TABLE AND GET THE
INVITATIONS OUT AND MAKE LABOR
AND INDUSTRY SIT DOWN TOGETHER
AND WORK OUT THE DEALS THAT
BENEFIT ALL OF US.
IF YOU ON THAT POINT AS YOU KNOW
THERE IS AT LEAST ONE BILL
PROPOSE THAT WOULD CREATE SUCH A
COMMISSION.
AND I WOULD SAY.
TO THE CONCERNS THAT YOU ALL
EXPRESS ABOUT MEMBERS NOT BEING
HERE. THAT WE'D LIKE TO INVITE
YOU TO GIVE PARTY TESTIMONY
AGAIN. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT
COMMISSION.
PUMP THEIR SEVERAL OF THE BILLS
I THINK RELATE. AND YOU KNOW
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF WHAT WE
DO THIS ON THE LABOR COMMITTEE
WE LIKE GIVEN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY. GIVE THE KEY POINTS
AGAIN AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S A. INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OR JUST BECAUSE IT'S ONE
OF THE BUSIER DAYS BUT ON WE
DON'T WANT THE POINTS TO BE
MISSED IN IF YOU'RE WILLING. I
LIKE TO ASK OUR STAFF TO WORK
WITH YOU ON HOW WE WE'VE BEEN TO
THAT AGENDA WILL WERE ACTUALLY
VOTING ON THOSE BILLS. AN
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU TO MAKE THOSE
PRESENTATIONS OF THAT THERE
HEARD.
AND.
I THINK YOU YOU GOT IT ACROSS
PRETTY CLEARLY EACH OF YOU IN
YOUR TESTIMONY THAT. ARE.
NO MATTER WHAT INNOVATION AND
NO MATTER WHAT COST SAVING GETS
CREATED THERE CERTAIN THINGS
ABOUT HAVING.
THE WORK FORCE THAT CANNOT BE.
CANNOT REPLACE AND THAT NO
COMPANY OR ORGANIZATION IS WHAT
IT IS WITHOUT ITS WORK FORCE AND
I THINK YOU'VE. YOU'VE CERTAINLY
DONE YOUR MEMBERS.
EXTREME JUSTICE IN GETTING THAT
ACROSS.
YEAH I WON ACTUAL COUPLE
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT BE
PROVOCATIVE THOUGH BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME. THAT WE ARE IN THIS
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE MOMENT. AND
YOU KNOW THESE COMPANIES ARE
MOVING FORWARD WITH CERTAIN
THINGS AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THEY DO. HAVE AT THE HEART OF
THEM PROFIT MAKING EXPENSE
SAVING AND. DIRECTLY THE LOSS OF
JOBS UNLESS THERE IS SOME
ABOUT THAT AND.
YOU KNOW ONE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PRESENCE OF OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. AND I ITE
WHENEVER SHE'S READY IF SHE
WANTS TO MAKE SOME REMARKS BUT
ARE WE ARE WE AT SOME. AYE
INEVITABLE PLACE INEVITABLE
CONFLICT WHERE COMPANIES WANT TO
MAKE PROFIT THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
AS THEY WANT TO SAVE MONEY
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO AND THAT WE
ARE AT AN UNAVOIDABLE CONFLICT
THAT IS CURRENTLY PITTING.
THAT INTERESTS WITH THE
LIKELIHOOD OF JOBS BEING LOST AS
A RESULT ARE WE THERE.
I'M.
I THINK THAT THEY CAN COEXIST.
I THINK THAT THERE IS A REALITY
THAT IN AND I THINK WE'VE SEEN
THIS IN PUBLIC SERVICES WHERE
YOU COULD FIND EFFICIENCIES AND
PROTECT JOBS AT THE SAME TIME. I
THINK WHEN THE GOAL STARTS OFF
WITH ONE ONLY ONE IN MIND WHICH
IS COST SAVINGS THAT ONE IS
GONNA FALL WITH IT AND THE SAME
TO THE CONTRARY IF IF THE GOAL
IN MIND IS ONLY TO SAVE WORKERS
AND YOU'RE NOT REALLY LOOKING AT
INNOVATION. THEN YOU DON'T
ACHIEVE BOTH GOALS I'VE SEEN IN
THE MEDI CAL OPERATION WE'VE
WE'VE ALLOWED ONLINE
APPLICATIONS BUT WE CREATED A NO
WRONG DOOR POLICY THAT'S WHAT WE
WE NAMED IT IN THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT. YOU CAN GO THROUGH ANY
DOOR YOU WANT TO TO RECEIVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR PROGRAMS YOU CAN
GO TALK TO SOMEONE IN PERSON YOU
CAN APPLY ON YOUR SMARTPHONE YOU
CAN APPLY FOR PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY AT A HOSPITAL. YOU
CAN GO TO A NAVIGATOR AND APPLY
FOR ELIGIBILITY BUT THERE'S
ALWAYS A NEED FOR WORKER. SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN MEDI CAL WHAT WE DID
IS NO ONE CAN DETERMINE YOUR
HERE IT FIXED ELIGIBILITY AND
LESS IT'S A HUMAN BEING
ELIGIBILITY WORKER. THE SYSTEM
CAN TELL YOU THAT THEY THINK
THAT YOU'RE ELIGIBLE BASED ON
THE INFORMATION YOU PROVIDE BUT
A WORKER A HUMAN BEING IS WHO
YOU GUYS HAVE ENTRUSTED TO
ACTUALLY DETERMINE IF THEY
RECEIVE STATE AND FEDERAL
BENEFITS. AND SO I THINK THERE'S
A WAY THAT YOU CAN DO BOTH AND
IF IF IF THE GOAL IN MIND A
GUINNESS TO INNOVATE. AND.
HONOR THE WORKERS THAT YOU HAVE
AND AND AND REALIZE THAT THEY'RE
IMPORTANT TO ANY INFRASTRUCTURE
THEN THERE IS A WAY THAT THAT
CAN THAT CAN CO EXIST. THE
REALITY IS THERE MIGHT BE SOME
CHANGES IN AND JOB ASSIGNMENTS
THERE MIGHT BE WORKERS THAT YOU
TRANSITION TO SOMETHING THAT
ENHANCES THEIR EXPERIENCE
THROUGH AN ONLINE APPLICATION.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY HAVE
THE SAME JOB OR MAYBE EVEN THE
SAME CLASSIFICATION BUT I THINK
THAT THERE IS A WAY THAT WE CAN
UTILIZE A WORKFORCE THAT WE HAVE
ESPECIALLY IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
WHAT TRYING TO BE INNOVATIVE
AND GIVE CLIENTS THE ABILITY TO
APPLY FOR SERVICES IN A MORE
CONVENIENT WAY AS A BLACK ON THE
SAME QUESTION AND COULD I ASK
YOU TO THINK BACK TO YOUR
EXAMPLE THAT YOU GAVE ABOUT?
THE.
.
THE DELIVERY ROBOTS AND I
THOUGHT WHEN YOU SAID THAT IT
THAT MAKES THE JOB SAFER FOR
EMPLOYEES AT THE AYE THAT'S A
GREAT THING I THOUGHT OKAY WE
CAN USE A AYE TO CREATE SAFETY
AND THAT'S A REALLY GOOD GOAL.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE IDEA OF.
HILL SAW DRIVING CARS.
AND AND THEY SAID THAT SOFT
DRIVING CARS WILL MAKE THE ROAD
SAFER FOR ALL OF US AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE JUST LOOK AT MY
DRIVING RECORD WHEN THEY CAME UP
WITH THIS BUT.
IT SEEMS NOBLE TO SAY THAT YES
YOU CAN CREATE A SCENARIO WHERE
THERE FEWER ACCIDENTS.
BUT ISN'T THERE AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
THE CONSEQUENCE THAT THERE WILL
BE FEWER PEOPLE TO DRIVE
VEHICLES AND THAT WILL BE JOB
LOSS.
YEAH WELL SO LET'S THINK ABOUT
THIS FOR MEDICS THEM BE BACK
HERE ON THURSDAY TO MEET WITH
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
WHO ARE DEVELOPING REGULATIONS
FOR SELF DRIVING TRUCKS THEY
JUST RELEASED?
THERE REGULATIONS FOR SELF
DRIVING CARS.
IT SHOULD BE ON THE ROADS OF
CALIFORNIA NEXT MONTH AND I'M
SURE MANY OF YOU HEARD THAT
YESTERDAY A SELF DRIVING CAR
UBER CAR KILLED SOMEBODY.
IN ARIZONA.
I AM CONVINCED NOW FROM TALKING
TO SOME OF THE COMPANIES THAT
ARE DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY AROUND
THESE TRUCKS THAT.
.
WE'RE ON THE CUSP.
WE COULD GO THAT DIRECTION.
WHERE?
THE NEW TRUCKS THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED.
COULD. REALIZE SIGNIFICANT FUEL
SAVINGS
FOR THE COMPANIES SO THEY WOULD
SAVE MONEY.
WHERE IT COULD MAKE OUR MEMBERS
JOB SAFER BECAUSE THEY WOULD
HAVE THINGS LIKE DRIVERS CYSTIC
TECHNOLOGY THAT PROTECT THEM
THAT STOPPED THE TRUCK IN THE
EVENT OF ACCIDENTS AND I'VE
ACTUALLY? STOOD IN FRONT OF
DRIVERLESS BUSES AS A TEST WITH
ONE OF OUR EMPLOYERS TRANSDEV.
I'M STILL HERE SO.
AT ME WITH HER CROWD HELP ME I'M
STILL HERE. YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE MY WIFE DIDN'T KNOW
THE.
THE THE TECHNOLOGY IS ACTUALLY
THERE THE COULD HELP.
THESE TRUCKS ARE REALLY
EXPENSIVE PIECES
OF MACHINERY.
THEY REQUIRE SKILLS THAT ARE
MEMBERS WHO DRIVE FOR UPS AND
OTHER COMPANIES DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE.
TALKING TO SOME THE
MANUFACTURER'S I ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT IF OUR MEMBERS IF
WE WORKED WITH THEM TO TRAIN OUR
MEMBERS UP TO HAVE THE SKILLS TO
DRIVE THIS EXPENSIVE EQUIPMENT.
THAT THEY IN TURN WOULD HAVE
MORE EARNING POWER AND MORE
PRODUCTIVE SAY FOR JOBS AND THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE MOVING GOODS
WOULD REALIZE COST SAVINGS IN
THE PROCESS. THAT'S A WIN WIN
FORMULA.
BUT IF THE D. M. V.. ROLLS OUT
REGULATIONS. BUT JUST LETS THESE
COMPANIES DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
WITH LITTLETON CHEN OR
CONSEQUENCES.
THEN THAT'S THE LOSE LOSE
SCENARIO FOR EVERYBODY EXCEPT
FOR THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
LOOKING TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
PROFITS AND SAVE COSTS AT THE
EXPENSE OF WORKERS LIKE MY
SISTER HERE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
SO I IF I WOULD SAY.
I'M A I'M A FIRM BELIEVER IN
THE QUOTE THAT THE ARCHITECT
HISTORY BENDS TOWARDS JUSTICE.
BUT IT'S OUR ROLE TO BEND THAT
ARC OF HISTORY TOWARDS JUSTICE
AND AND I DO THINK WE HAVE REAL
CHOICES IN THIS MATTER AND
NOTHING IS INEVITABLE. NO THE
ACCEPTANCE THAT TECHNOLOGICAL
YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGICAL
REVOLUTION YOU KNOW THAT IT'S
HAPPENING IS INEVITABLE IS ONE
THAT I THAT I DON'T BELIEVE IN.
AND I THINK THERE'S A REAL WAY
TO THINK ABOUT HOW EACH OF US
UNDERSTAND OUR ROLES IN THAT
EQUATION BUSINESS HAS A ROLE.
GOVERNMENT HAS A ROLE LABOR HAS
A ROLE. WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THAT TRUE PARTNERSHIP LOOKS
LIKE IT I THINK YOU KNOW.
DOUG JUST GIVE YOU A VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW SUITED TO GIVE
A VERY GOOD EXAMPLE. IN OUR
WORLD.
YOU NO IN ESPECIALLY THE RETAIL
GROCERY SETTING YOU KNOW THERE'S
THIS BIG THING ABOUT AMAZON GO
RIGHT YOU DON'T HAVE THESE YOU
KNOW THAT HAVE THE STORES ARE NO
EMPLOYEES AND IT.
IT HE WAS GONNA WALK AND TAKE
THEIR STUFF IN THE BAG AND THEN
LEAVE AND EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE
ON HIS OWN ACCOUNT AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S CAN BE GREAT.
YOU KNOW.
THAT WILL BE A PART OF SOME OF
THIS DISCUSSION AND IT'S GONNA
BE A PART OF THE YOU KNOW THE
ECONOMIC EQUATION BUT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO EMPLOYERS. AND WHAT
EMPLOYERS TELL US THE ONES THAT
REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH US TO
SAID LOOK.
WE ACCEPT THAT THE ROLE OF THE
WORKER IS GONNA CHANGE AND WE
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU TO CHANGE
THAT ROLE TOGETHER. RIGHT
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHEN PEOPLE COME INTO THE STORE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW EVERYONE
HERE GO SHOPPING ON SUNDAY
MORNING I MEAN OR WHATEVER DAY I
GO SHOPPING Y. FAMILY THAT'S AN
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU SHARE WITH
YOUR FAMILY. YOU GET TO KNOW
YOUR READ SO CLERK YOU TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHATEVER PIECE OF
FRUIT OR YOU KNOW PIECE OF MEAT
THAT YOU HONOR SOME WINE THAT
YOU WANT TO TASTE.
PEOPLE LIKE THAT ACTUALLY TEND
TO BUY MORE THINGS
RIGHT SO IT'S ABOUT HOW WE RE
READ RETRAIN.
THE WORKERS IN THOSE STORES TO
TO HELP ADAPT TO THAT
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE IMPROVING
AND IT'S A CHOICE. ITS A CHOICE
THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE TO MAKE AND
THAT IS ALSO A CHOICE THAT I
THINK WE AS A SOCIETY HAVE TO
MAKE. IN IN LABOR WHERE YOU KNOW
WITH WHAT WE HAVE LEFT
AGAIN OUR FIRM ARE PLACE IN THIS
DISCUSSION. RIGHT AND I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA SEE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT UNIONS TACKLE THESE
ISSUES BUT I THINK IT'S A REAL
CHOICE AND I DO THINK WE CAN
BEND THAT ARC OF HISTORY TOWARDS
JUSTICE. AT READING THROUGH
THESE THINGS I THINK IT'S
LEGISLATORS AND CONCERN POLICY
MAKERS I THINK THERE'S A LOT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE CAN
SHOW AS EXAMPLES FOR US THE
COUNTRY.
THE ART DOESN'T BEND BY ITSELF
TREND DOWN THE STREET WILL STATE
AND SOMEONE WHO KNOWS SOMETHING
ABOUT THEM IN THE ARE TOWARD
SOCIAL JUSTICE. ACTUALLY NEVER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AND AM I WANNA APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING HERE AT TWO OTHER
COMMITTEES I WAS SITTING IN THIS
MORNING SO. I I DIDN'T GET TO
SEE ALL OF THE GREAT TESTIMONIUM
SHORE.
BUT WHAT I THINK I THINK THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AS ONE WHO
HAS. CONSISTENTLY FOUGHT AGAINST
THIS NOTION THAT.
WERE IN A PREDETERMINED COURSE
OF
OF ACTION IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS LITTLE ICE
WATCH THE JETSONS AND WOOD BUT
WAS TOLD THAT BY THE TIME I GREW
UP THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD BE
LIVING AND.
.
STILL WAITING ON MY. LITTLE
TRANSFORMER. SPACESHIP BOMB.
SO I THINK A LOT OF A LOT OF
THE.
TALKS TOWARDS.
AUTOMATION WILD SOME THE TALK
IS HYPERBOLE AND AND WE HAVE TO
ACCEPT THAT AND IT'S USED SO
OFTEN. TO.
SUPPRESS THE CURRENT WAGES OF
WORKERS BOMB YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO LOSE YOUR JOB TO A
ROBOT. IF WE DEMAND A REASONABLE
WAGE.
ITS USE TO TO CHANGE THE NATURE
OF EMPLOYEES TEND PET
CONTRACTORS IT'S USED
UNFORTUNATELY.
AT AS A WAY I THINK TO TO PUT
DOWN MARKERS.
BUT THERE'S A CERTAIN SENSE OF
REALITY WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH
THAT AYE TO REMIND FOLKS
CONSTANTLY.
I REMEMBER. AS WE WENT TOWARDS
TECHNOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE WHICH HAS
SOME SUCCESS AS FAR AS. I'M
UNBIASED POLICING AND AND READ
CAMERA LIGHTS RIGHT. AND THAT
pTHING IN IN THERE SOME POSITIVE
TO THE YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT GOING
GET PULLED OVER FOR DRIVING
WHILE BLACK OR BROWN JUST
BECAUSE.
YOUR EAR IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
INTERSECTION BUT THEN CITIES
TOOK AUDITOR'S DOWNS BECAUSE
THERE ARE OTHER CONCERNS PRIVACY
CONCERNS ON THEY'D THEY'D KEPT
GLITCHES YOU KNOW. I'M WE WE
ENJOY AND APPRECIATE A HUMAN
FACTOR I THINK A LOT OF WHAT WE
JAIL AND I THINK THAT SOMETIMES.
WE YOU KNOW. DON'T RECOGNIZE IT
UNTIL IT'S GONE AND SO.
I THINK I WHEN I LOOK AT MY
GROCERY STORE AND I SEE SELF
CHECK LINES.
I'M NOT THE ONLY PERSON I MEAN
I REFUSE TO GO TO A SUBJECT
LINE.
AND I'LL REMIND OUR UFCW
MEMBERS PLEASE DON'T TELL ME HOW
TO. TAKE AWAY YOUR JOB AND HOW
TO USE THAT I REFUSE TO DO THAT.
ARE ARE THE REALITY OF WHAT WE
LIVE WITH AND AND IT'S NOT BEING
ADDRESSED. AND WE'RE GONNA NEED
WORKERS WERE GONNA CONTINUE TO
NEED WORKERS.
AND SO I'M GLAD YOU GUYS ARE
COMING TO THE TABLE AND HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION I THINK IT'S A
NECESSARY DISCUSSION. I HOPE I'M
THAT BUSINESS LIKEWISE WILL COME
TO THE TABLE AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION NOT JUST IMPOSE.
A MOMENTARY SOLUTION AND AND SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE I LOOK
FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE.
.
I THINK YOU'RE CRAZY FORGET IN
FRONT OF ALL DRIVERLESS CAR BUT.
YEAH NOW I'LL I'LL I'LL I'LL
I'LL LEAVE MY TRASH IN THE HANDS
AT A TEAMSTER DRIVER ANYDAY.
OVER A ROBOT
SO. WITH THAT I'M THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO.
OUR CONTINUED DISCUSSION THE
SERENA.
THEY DO IT JUST DAWNED ON ME
NORMALLY BOTH OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEES MEET ON WEDNESDAY.
AND THIS AND THAT UP BEING A
SPECIAL MEETING AND SO WE LIKE
TO HAVE ANOTHER CRACK AT IT. ON
A REGULAR SCHEDULE DAY REMEMBERS
NO ONE EXPECTED COME TO LIVE
COMMITTEE AND.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU SHARED
AND.
KNOW THAT WE HEAR YOU AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL.
BOTTOM TO THE POINT THAT WHICH
IS MADE WE DO HAVE SOME EMPLOYER
REPRESENTATIVES WHO HAVE COME
FORWARD TO SAID THEY WANT TO BE
AT THE TABLE I KNOW THAT THEY'D
MET THIS WEEK. BOB WITH
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE LABOR
FEDERATION AND WE WANT TO CALL
THEM FOR IT SO THAT WE CAN HEAR
FROM OUR EMPLOYERS. AND THEIR
INPUT INTO THIS CONVERSATION.
AND AGAIN TO THOSE FROM MY
LABOR PANEL AS WE ASK OF OUR.
ACADEMIA PANEL IF YOU CAN STAY
WILL BE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER.
WE WOULD LIKE TO.
HAD TO BE PRESIDENT THE THINGS
THAT YOU WISH TO ADDRESS.
BUT WE ARE PLEASED TO DAY TO
HAVE. A REPRESENTING.
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP FOUNDATION BRIAN BRANNON
AND UP FROM OUR OWN.
TECHNET HERE.
ANDREA DEVOTE AND WE WELCOME
YOU BOTH AND WE'RE READY FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY.
GREAT DOESN'T THINK VERY MUCH.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ACTUALLY HONORED TO BE HERE MY
NAME IS BRIAN BRANNEN I'M SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP US OF
JUST A QUICK CLARIFICATION NOT
OUR FOUNDATION WHICH IS A
SEPARATE. ENTITY YES SIR.
WE REPRESENT THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY COMPANIES WITH A PRESENCE
IN SILICON VALLEY INTO PUBLIC
POLICY ON THEIR BEHALF WERE
ABSOLUTELY HONORED. TO BE HERE
NOT LEAST BECAUSE WE TRULY
BELIEVE THAT THE QUESTIONS ARE
DISCUSSING ARE AMONG THE
QUESTIONS OF OUR TIME AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
CONSIDERING THEM IN FACT.
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN MONTHS OUR
FOUNDATION RC THREE AND CITY
THAT YOU MENTIONED HAS BEEN
CONVENING MEMBERS OF YOUR STAFF
OTHER STAFF OF OTHER MEMBERS IN
COMMITTEES. SPECIFICALLY TO
DISCUSS ISSUES AROUND THIS AND
NOT TO NOT TO CONVEY A POINT OF
VIEW BUT RATHER TO CONVENE
VOICES FROM LABOR FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS CONSUMER
ADVOCATES ACADEMICS CERTAINLY
TECHNOLOGISTS. TO BEGIN TO
GRAPPLE WITH THESE ISSUES AND
AND TO HELP YOUR STAFF GRAPPLE
WITH THEM AS WELL SO.
AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE VERY INVOLVED
IN THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING US
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TOUCH ON
THREE POINTS DURING MY TESTIMONY
FIRST. I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THE OVERWHELMINGLY POSITIVE
IMPACT THAT TECHNOLOGY HAS HAD
OVER TIME IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OUR ECONOMY SECOND.
SOMETIMES THOSE IMPACTS ARE
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT BEFORE THE
FACT AND I WANNA SPEAK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE BIT AND THEN
THIRDLY FROM A POLICY INVENTION
PERSPECTIVE. WE'VE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WORKFORCE BUT I
WANT TO DRILL DOWN ON THAT IF
THAT'S AN AREA THAT WE SEE. AS
AS VERY VERY PROMISING.
SO FIRST IN GENERAL I REALLY
HOPE THAT ONE OF OUR TAKEAWAYS
TODAY. IS THAT THE DEPLOYMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IN THE ECONOMY HAS
OVER TIME GENERALLY BEEN
OVERWHELMINGLY. POSITIVE.
IT'S DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
PRODUCTIVITY.
LEADING TO HIGHER INCOMES
GREATER DEMAND AND NEW JOBS.
IN CALIFORNIA BETWEEN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX AND TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN MEDIAN WAGES PARA PARDON
ME.
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME HAS
ALSO INCREASED FROM JUST OVER
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO OVER SIX
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
FORCING INCREASE IN THE QUANTITY
OF JOBS AS WELL AS THE QUALITY.
IT ALSO GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT
TECHNOLOGY TRANSITIONS OF HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE COST ON CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES AND CERTAIN
GEOGRAPHIES. WE FEEL IT IS
ABSOLUTELY INCUMBENT UPON ALL OF
US TO INVEST IN THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE EL WHO ARE IMPACTED BY THE
STERN BY THESE TRANSITIONS NOT
JUST BECAUSE. THE INHERENT
DIGNITY OF THOSE PEOPLES AT
STAKE FIRST AND FOREMOST BEAT
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE NEED TO
BRING TO BEAR THE ENERGIES OF
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
THE MOST COMPETITIVE. PLACE THAT
IT CAN BE.
NOW TO LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
THE BEST RESEARCH THE PRINT
THAT'S BEEN DONE REGARDING A AYE
AND THE FUTURE OF WORK POSES
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS. BUT RATHER
THAN PROVIDING ANSWERS IT LOOKS
TWO SCENARIOS.
THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HARD
TO PREDICT THE FUTURE. IT'S
REALLY HARD TO PROACTIVELY MAKE
POLICY AND GET IT RIGHT.
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THE
EXAMPLE OF THE TEN MINUTES IT
WAS DEPLOYED IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. MANY REASONABLE PEOPLE
PERHAPS THE MOST REASONABLE
PEOPLE. THOUGHT THAT THE ATM WAS
GOING TO DECIMATE THE YEAR
FRANKS OF BANK TELLERS.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IN FACT THE NUMBER OF BANK
TELLERS INCREASE OVER TIME AS
BANKS HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF BRANCHES
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
AND RATHER THAN GOING TO LOWER
QUALITY JOBS IT ENABLED THOSE
TELLERS TO ENABLE NEW PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES.
SO AGAIN WE SAW BOTH COUNTER
INTUITIVELY MORE JOBS. AND
HIGHER QUALITY JOBS.
YEAH WELL YOU MIGHT HEAR LESS
OF.
ITS IT IN THE RECESSION. MANY OF
THOSE RETAIL OUTLETS CLOSED.
BECAUSE OF THE OVERALL IMPACT
THE ECONOMY SINCE THAT TIME.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN MOBILE BANKING
COME IN AS A FORCE IN THOSE JOBS
HAVEN'T COME BACK.
MY POINT HERE IS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO KNOW. HOW A GIVEN
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO IMPACT
THE ECONOMY? AND WHEN.
THE GOOD THING FROM OUR VIEW.
IS THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN DO. BOTH TO LEVERAGE THE
ENORMOUS POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF A
AYE. AND TO RALLY AROUND THOSE
WHO BEAR THE COSTS
IT'S SOMETHING WOULD BE
CRITICAL.
EVEN IF WE FROZE TODAY'S ECONOMY
IN PLACE AS IT IS FOR THE NEXT
FIFTY YEARS. AND THAT IS
CREATING A NIMBLE WORLD CLASS
WORKFORCE.
WHAT IS THIS MEAN WELL? THERE'S
A LOT OF DETAIL I COULD GO INTO
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST RE
SKILLING CONSTANT FEET
CONSTANTLY RENEWING SKILLS AND
THIS IS FOR EVERYONE AT EVERY
POINT ON THE SKILLS SPECTRUM
THAT'S FRANKLY FOR ALL OF US IN
THIS ROOM. WHO NEED TO
CONSTANTLY BE THINKING ABOUT
WHERE WILL I BE IN FIVE YEARS?
WITH AN ECONOMY THAT'S CHANGING
SO QUICKLY WHAT SKILLS DO I NEED
TO DEVELOP SUCH THAT IT'S NOT
WHEN I LOSE MY JOB THAT SUDDENLY
I'M LOOKING AROUND THINKING OH
NO I'VE GOT TO RE SKILL. BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE'VE STRUGGLE TO FIND
OUT FIND MODELS THAT WILL WORK.
NOW THAT SAID WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SEVENTEEN IN OUR AREA
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS MATCHING THEM WITH
EMPLOYERS. TO INFORM CURRICULA
AND ALSO TO MATCH THEM WITH
INTERNSHIPS AND JOB SHADOWING
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE MANY OTHER
EXAMPLES CERTAINLY IN THE RE
SKILLING OF THE LABOR MOVEMENT
HAS TREMENDOUS EXPERIENCE IN
APPRENTICESHIPS EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANELS. TODAY WE HAVE
KHANACADEMY AND LINKED IN
LEARNING AS TOOLS THAT ARE
BROUGHT BETTER ACCESSIBLE
FEDERAL LOW COST CANDIDLY WERE
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO LEVERAGE THOSE TOOLS WELL.
BUT THEY ARE PART OF THE MIX AND
WE THINK THERE'S A BY A
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL THERE.
THE RAPID CHANGE IN OUR ECONOMY
ALSO REINFORCES JUST HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR OUR KEY
TWELVE SYSTEM PREPARE OUR
STUDENTS FOR THE FUTURE.
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE EQUIP ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR ULTIMATE PROFESSIONS
WITH SKILLS TO SUCCESSFULLY
NAVIGATING CONTRIBUTE. TO OUR
ECONOMY AND SOCIETY IN HERE ON
THAT BOBAK CONCERNS COMMENT AT
THE HEARING SEVERAL WEEKS AGO
AND ASSEMBLY PRIVACY. THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY HAVE MORE STUDENTS
STUDYING POTTERY IN CALIFORNIA
THAN COMPUTER SCIENCE
WE GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO ON
THIS FRONT AND IT'S ALSO IT IS
ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT THIS
STARTS.
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS ALSO A
CRITICAL PIECE ON THE SEVENTH
SUM. TO REALIZE THE GREAT
POTENTIAL OF BENEFITS.
WE'RE STILL.
I RESPECT EXACTLY RIGHTS OF THAT
CAME FROM THE THE GAP FROM THE
INTERNET TECHNOLOGY IN
EDUCATION.
AND INNOVATION FOUNDATION OF
WASHINGTON DC BASED A AND TO THE
PRESIDENT ROBERT ATKINSON
TESTIFIED AT THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE HEARING ON
THIS TOPIC TWO WEEKS AGO.
YEAH YEAH. YEAH.
THERE IS A BILL THAT WOULD
EXPAND FUNDING FOR.
COMPUTER SCIENCE. EDUCATION IN
OUR STATE AND MULTIPLE DISTRICTS
AND.
I KNOW THAT THE SILICON VALLEY
GROUP HAS BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN
THAT PERHAPS YOU ALL SUPPORTED
SPONSORED A NOTE TECHNIQUES FOR
WORKING VERY CLOSELY SALUTE AND
ON THE NO AND AS A MATTER FACT
OAKLAND OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
DISTRICT DEL SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE
AMONG THE LEADERS. IN THIS SPACE
PASSED SO THAT WE KNOW THE
AUTHOR AND IF YOU WANT TALK TO
YEAH YES SIR BE HAPPY TO HELP
YOU CONNECT YES SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO. SO IN SOME OF
OVERALL OVERALL OVER TIME
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE BENEFITS IN
TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY WE KNOW THAT
THEIR COSTS BUT FOR BOTH OF
THOSE WERE IMPACTED BY THOSE
COSTS. AND THOSE WHO ARE GOING
TO BE MAKING THE NEW OF
INNOVATION CAN.
ECONOMY AND CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION IS REALLY THE CENTER
FROM A PUBLIC POLICY PERSPECTIVE
FROM OUR FEW TO THANKS AGAIN FOR
HAVING I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THE BILL WHO OUT THERE THINK YOU
I AM I CAN STILL SAY GOOD
MORNING BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT I'M
STANDING BETWEEN PUBLIC COMMENT
AND LUNCH.
SO I'VE FIVE TRIED TO REDUCE MY
TESTIMONY ASSEMBLY I COULD SAY
ME TOO I CAN ALSO I ALSO WANNA
START MY COMMENTS OFF.
BY SAYING HOW ENCOURAGED I AM
BY THE CONVERSATION THIS
MORNING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN FOR I'M
HAVING US HERE AT THE TABLE.
AND REALLY.
HOPE THAT THIS SENDS THE RIGHT
MESSAGE THAT WE ARE HERE TO
COLLABORATE WE ARE HERE TO SIT
AT THE TABLE.
AND WHERE I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
BE HERE.
AND THRILLED TO BE WORKING OUT
WITH NOT ONLY THE COMMITTEE.
BUT THE THE PRIOR AYE WITNESSES
AND ORGANIZATIONS GOING FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT.
TECHNET SO I'M. ANDREA TO MOW
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF ATTACK NOT
WHO I REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY OF
THE NATION'S LEADING TECHNOLOGY
AND INNOVATION COMPANIES.
OUR DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES
DYNAMIC START UPS TO THE MOST
ICONIC COMPANIES ON THE PLANET.
AND WE REPRESENT MORE THAN THREE
MILLION EMPLOYEES NATIONWIDE.
ALL STARTED BY SAYING THE FUTURE
OF WORK IS THE FUTURE OF
EVERYTHING FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WORK IS THE REASON WE
GET OUT OF BED EVERY MORNING. IT
IS THE WAY WE SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES WE BUILD TOWARDS OUR
DREAMS AND IS A CORE PART OF OUR
SUBSTANCE CORE SENSE OF
OURSELVES.
WE'RE LIVING IN A TIME OF
EXTRAORDINARY CHANGE.
AS PRIOR WITNESSES US SORT OF
REFER TO SOME ARE CALLING THIS
THE FOURTH INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION
OR THE DIGITAL REVOLUTION AND
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU CALL IT.
WE'RE LIVING IN A TIME WHERE
EVERY INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS
INDUSTRY AND GOVERNMENT IS BEING
IMPACTED BY BREAKTHROUGHS IN
COMPUTING POWER. CAN ACTIVITY
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY
BIOTECHNOLOGY AND OTHER
INNOVATIONS.
THERE'S BEEN A CONVERSATION
GOING ON GLOBALLY.
AND NATIONALLY ON THE
CONSEQUENTIAL STORY OF ROBOTICS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND THE
REVERBERATIONS A MIGHT HAVE ON
JOBS IN THE ECONOMY. IT IS
UNDENIABLE THAT AUTOMATION AND
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WILL
BRING ABOUT SUBSTANTIAL
INNOVATION TO SEVERAL SECTORS OF
THE ECONOMY.
ECONOMISTS ARE HOPEFUL LIKE THAT
LIKE THE INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION
IN THIS NEW ERA WILL CREATE AS
MANY JOBS AS IT DISPLACES.
TODAY A AYE AND MACHINE LEARNING
ARE PRIMARILY USED IN INDUSTRY
TO AUGMENT HUMANS IN SECTORS
LIKE MANUFACTURING AND
TRANSPORTATION. LARGELY FOCUSED
AROUND IMPROVING QUALITY OF LIFE
AND SAFETY.
AN EQUALLY ARE BEING USED TO
MAKE HUMAN SMARTER AND DOMAINS
LIKE CUSTOMER SERVICE. WE
BELIEVE IT'S INCUMBENT ON US AS
LEADERS TO SPEND MORE TIME
SHARING THE BENEFITS OF A AYE
AND THE WAYS THAT TECHNOLOGY IS
MAKING LIFE BETTER TODAY.
NETFLIX AND AMAZON USE A AYE TO
MAKE BETTER RECOMMENDATIONS.
SOON THE SAME TECHNOLOGY WILL BE
USED TO IMPROVE ALL OTHER
ASPECTS OF DAILY LIFE FROM
EDUCATION. TO CRIME PREVENTION
AND AGRICULTURE TO HEALTH CARE.
AGAIN IF YOU LOOK AT HUMAN
HISTORY ANYTIME THERE'S BEEN
SOME MAJOR TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION YOU ULTIMATELY HAVE
SOME SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
PRODUCTIVITY. WHICH THEN CREATES
THE NEED FOR A NEW SET OF
INDUSTRIES AND JOBS.
TECHNOLOGY IS NEITHER GOOD NOR
BAD. IT'S WHAT YOU DO WITH IT
THE MAKES THE DIFFERENCE.
TECHNOLOGY CAN SOLVE PROBLEMS
STREAMLINED PROCESS WORK FLOWS
AND INNOVATIONS CAN CHANGE THE
WAY WE LIVE WHICH CONSEQUENCE
LOOK CONSEQUENTLY ALLOWS US TO
START TO PUT. AND A PIPE PEOPLE
TO ISSUES AND PROBLEMS THAT WERE
UNIQUELY CAPABLE OF DOING AND
SOLVING.
THIS NEW REVOLUTION OFFERS
BOUNDLESS POSSIBILITIES HOWEVER
IT ALSO CREATES A HIGH DEGREE OF
DIFFICULTY FOR POLICY MAKERS AND
REGULATORS TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH THE RAPID PACE OF CHANGE.
IT'S EASIER TO IDENTIFY THE
BUSINESSES OR THE INDUSTRIES AND
JOB FUNCTIONS THAT WELL OR COULD
BE REPLACED OR BETTER SERVED BY
INNOVATION INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES AND AUTOMATION. IT
IS MUCH HARDER TO IMAGINE THE
THINGS THAT WILL BE BORN OUT OF
THAT INNOVATION AND THE NEW
INDUSTRIES AND JOB FUNCTIONS
THAT CAN AND WILL EMERGE.
TOGETHER WE MUST FOCUS ON THE
WORK FORCE.
THIS STARTS WITH PRE K. AND K.
THROUGH TWELVEEDUCATION. IN THE
U. S. ALONE THERE ARE MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND OPEN
TECHNOLOGY JOBS
BUT OUR UNIVERSITIES PRODUCE
ONLY ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
SCIENCE GRADUATES A YEAR.
ACCORDING TO STATISTICS RECENTLY
RELEASED IN CALIFORNIA.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT OPEN COMPUTING JOBS THAT'S
THREE POINT FIVE TIMES THE
AVERAGE DEMAND IN CALIFORNIA.
YET CALIFORNIA ONLY HAD FOUR
THOUSAND TWENTY NINE COMPUTER
SCIENCE GRAD SCAN PETER SCIENCE
GRADUATES IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
WE NEED TO PREPARE YOUNG PEOPLE
FOR THE WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW
INVESTING IN AREAS SUCH AS STEM
EDUCATION AND CREATING
APPRENTICESHIPS AS PASTOR CAREER
READINESS. AT THE SAME TIME WE
MUST CREATE PROGRAMS TO GIVE
TODAY'S WORKFORCE THE SKILLS
THEY NEED TO SUCCEED AND ADAPT
TO ONGOING TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE.
ADDITIONALLY COMPANIES OUR GREAT
UNIVERSITIES FOR EDUCATING THE
WORKFORCE OF THE FUTURE. THEY
INVEST IN TRAINING EMPLOYEES AS
WELL AS INTERNS AND APPRENTICES
TO DRIVE GROWTH AND INNOVATION
WHICH IN MANY CASES AMOUNTS TO
SPECIALIZED INSTRUCTION AND
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE. THAT CAN'T
BE OBTAINED AT EVEN THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITIES.
OUR LEADERS.
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE A LIKE YOU
SHOULD BE LOOKING TO ADOPT
SMART.
ADOPTIVE AND LONG RANGE
STRATEGIES THAT FOSTER
INNOVATION ENHANCE GLOBAL
COMPETITIVENESS.
PROMOTE JOB GROWTH AND RETENTION
AND HELP BUILD HIGHLY SKILLED
WORKFORCES OF TODAY AND THE
FUTURE.
THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING OF
MEMBER MAN MANY CONVERSATIONS
AND TECHNET STANDS READY TO WORK
TOGETHER. ON THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
WE LOOK FOR FUTURE DISCUSSION.
YOU.
BUT YOU KNOW I IT COULD WELL
EVERY PANEL I THINK WE HEARD
THAT THERE IS A TENSION.
BETWEEN.
INNOVATION.
.
SAFETY.
JOB ATTENTION. AND NEW JOB
CREATION AND. IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO
ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE HEARD TODAY.
OR ADD ANY NEW THOUGHTS ABOUT
THIS TENSION THAT.
AS I THINK EVERY SPEAKER HAS
SAID WE HAVE TO WRESTLE WITH
THIS THAT THIS SHOULD NOT BE AN
EITHER OR THING. THIS IS AN
INNOVATION AT THE AT THE EXPENSE
OF JOBS BUT SHOULD BE INNOVATION
THAT MAKES JOBS SAY FOR.
RESERVE JOBS AND CREATES NEW
JOBS ANYTHING THAT YOU ALL ADD
TO THE MENU OF WHAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY.
I THINK THE OTHER REASON REPEAT
IN A CONSUMER REPORT THAT SUB
AND CITED A COUPLE OF TIMES
REALLY CAPTURES I THINK A LOT OF
THE PROMISE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE WAYS THAT WE MIGHT THINK
ABOUT IT. WE CAN SEE THAT IT
THAT IN A NUMBER OF SECTORS
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE INCLUDING
A INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES THEY'RE
GOING TO BE A TONE OF
OPPORTUNITIES. IN THE COMING TEN
TO TWENTY YEARS OR SO I
DEFINITELY THINK THAT.
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
WHERE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES TO INVEST
IN THOSE PLACES. AROUND WHAT THE
SAME TIME SERVE LOOKING LOOKING
THOSE INDUSTRIES WHERE THERE'S
GOINGTO BE SOME DISPLACEMENT
AND THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
PREPARE NOT JUST THE FOLKS WERE
CURRENTLY IN THOSE JOBS BUT BUT
THEIR CHILDREN ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN. TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
JOBS ARE GOING TO BE AROUND IN
IN TEN YEARS.
I JUST MIGHT ALSO ADD ON ONE OF
THE THEMES I AGREE THAT THAT
THOSE THOSE ARE THE SAME THEMES
THAT WE HEARD OUT OF THE
AUDIENCE. I'M BUT I THINK IT'S
THE ENGAGEMENT WITH WORKERS AND
PROVIDING THE SOLUTIONS AS I
THINK IT WAS.
PERHAPS TIAS IT'S THAT IT'S THE
SORT OF INTEGRATION AND THE CO
EXISTING OF TECHNOLOGY AND
WORKERS I'M NOT JUST BLANKETING
A SOLUTION.
BECAUSE WE THINK IT SHOULD BE
SO BUT IT'S BACKUP COLLABORATION
THAT WILL PROVIDE EFFICIENCIES.
THROUGH TECHNOLOGY BUT YET
STILL SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE SO
TO ME I THINK THAT'S A COMMON
THREAD.
THAT SHOULD BE HIGHLIGHTED.
WHAT DO YOU DO ABOUT IT THAN
THAT I'M A I'M A WHAT WE DON'T
DO ABOUT A KIND OF PERSON RIGHT
I'M I'M LOOKING OUT I SEE I SEE
DOUG FROM THE TEAMSTERS ICT IF
MESS YEAH YOU GOT SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP HERE WE ARE
TECHNICALLY? WE DIVIDED THE ROOM
GET IT ALL SORTED OUT ALL FAITH
I MEAN LIKE THAT I MEAN LIKE IN
THE ROOM AND SORT OF HOW THE GUY
GOT EXCITED I SAY WE WILL PUT
OUR BY IN A ROOM.
AND SORTED OUT IN A WAY THAT'S
VERY SPECIFIC TO WHAT WE DO HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
LEADERS OF LABOR WE HAVE THE
LEADERS OF TECHNOLOGY AND
BUSINESS HERE.
WE HAVE SOME OF THE FINEST
INSTITUTIONS IN ACADEMIA WHO
PROVIDED US SOME SOME SOME
STORIES AND SOME DATA. ON THE WE
GOING TO ABOUT A WEEK AGO AND WE
CAN TO TAKE CARE OF THIS RIGHT
HERE AND NOW AND SO HOW DO WE
MAKE THIS A SPECIFIC THING. THAT
WASN'T JUST OUT A HAD A HEARING
AND THEN NOTHING HAPPENED BUT WE
ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I MEAN FROM MY VIEW ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS AS IT WERE ING
DISCUSSION AT A TIME WHEN IT'S
IT'S AN ODD I MET MY STATEMENT
TO SIR. BOOK AND IF YOU WOULD AS
YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT WE DO ABOUT
IT WOULD YOU BOTH TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE PREPARED O DO WHICH
IS COMMITTED TO DUKE TO HELP.
MAKE THAT HAPPEN YEAH SO
CERTAINLY WE WAIT THE LEADERSHIP
GROUP HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR A LONG
TIME THIS IS WHERE WHAT WITH ALL
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
UNCERTAINTY IN TERMS I MEAN EVEN
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BUILDING
TECHNOLOGIES. DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHICH ONES ARE GONNA BE
SUCCESSFUL WHICH BUSINESS MODELS
ARE GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL HOW
THEY'RE GONNA BE DEPLOYED WHAT
THE IMPACTS ARE GOING TO BE THIS
IS ONE OF THE GREAT CHALLENGES.
IT'S THAT UNCERTAINTY NOW
BUSINESS LEADERS HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS IN THAT CONTEXT AS TO
POLICYMAKERS SO IN OUR VIEW.
WITH THEIR LIVES TO MOST
OPPORTUNITY IS TO TAKE ACTION
WHERE AS OTHERS AND ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR RETURN TODAY.
TWO YEARS FROM NOW FIVE YEARS
FROM NOW TEN YEARS FROM NOW AND
WHERE WE HAVE I THINK VERY BROAD
CONSENSUS AMONG ALL OF THESE
FACTORS IS THAT SKILLS
DEVELOPMENT AT EACH POINT.
CRADLE TO CAREER IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL AND EQUIP BOTH FOR
CERTAINLY FOR COMPANIES IN A
QUESTION ABOUT THAT AS FOR
WORKERS AS WELL TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL BE THERE. SO THAT'S GONNA.
GO WORK FOR SEEMS TO BE A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN REACH CONSENSUS
VERY SOON YOUR LEGISLATION I
THINK SPEAKS OF THE.
SO I DO NOT THINK ABOUT THIS
LITTLE MORE SIMPLY WHEN MY FIFTY
YEAR OLD DOCTOR GETS REALLY
OVERWHELMED WITH CHEMISTRY WHICH
I CAN EVEN BEGIN TO HELP HER
WITH UNFORTUNATELY. I'M AYE
STUFF AYE TELLER START TO LOOK
AT IT LIKE A POSSIBLE RATE WHICH
PIECES DO YOU HAVE WHAT DO YOU
KNOW LET'S LET'S DECIDE WHICH
PIECES ARE MISSING. I I SORT OF
LOOK AT THIS IS NOT SAME WAY.
WE NEED TO START TO LOOK AT
WHAT PIECES ARE THERE.
SO THAT WE CAN TRULY IDENTIFY
WHAT PIECES ARE MISSING AND I
THINK WHAT WE'RE COMMITTED TO IS
HELPING TO PUT THE PUZZLE
TOGETHER.
SO MADE INVITATION FOR US ALL
GET A ROOM AND SORTED OUT I'LL
SPONSOR THE LIVES NOT JUST
BECAUSE I'M HUNGRY AND WANT TO
GO TO LUNCH BECAUSE.
I THINK IF WE DON'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF HAVING EVERYONE
WHO'S IN THE ROOM RIGHT NOW BE
IN A ROOM AND SAY OKAY WHAT WE
GONNA DO ABOUT TO COME UP WITH
THREE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
WHETHER IT'S WORKFORCE OF
SOMETHING ELSE. WE'VE MISSED THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I DON'T WANT TO
MISS AN OPPORTUNITY SO
APPRECIATE YOU SAYING YOU WANT
BE AT THE TABLE CINEMA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. I THINK. I JUST.
ONE ECHO YOUR EAR STATEMENT I
MEAN WE KNOW FOR BUSINESS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL YOU NEED CONSUMERS.
YOU KNOW WE WE NEED TO HAVE
FOLKS WHO WORK IS IMPORTANT.
AYE I GET VERY NERVOUS WHEN WE
LOOK AT SOLUTIONS SAID INCLUDE.
JUST PAIN PEOPLE NOT WORK.
AND SO I I THINK THAT HAVING
SOME DISCUSSIONS AROUND SOME
UNIVERSAL VALUES.
AT ABOUT THAT TRANSITION I
THINK ONE OF THINGS THAT HAS.
REALLY FRUSTRATED ME IS THIS
KIND OF LAKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A SERVICE BASED SOCIETY OR
WHATEVER WE HAVE NOW ARE BUT WE
HAVE HAD. AND WE'RE GONNA JOHN
TO THIS COMPLETELY AUTOMATED
SOCIETY WITH NO WORKERS AND WE
KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
AND GRAND WE ALL TALK IN
HYPERBOLE HERE SO SOMETIMES YOU
NOW WE GET CAUGHT UP IN THAT.
AND.
AND I HAVE A HARD TIME BECAUSE
I I THINK MY GUT REACTION AS A
FORMER LABOR LEADER IS TO BE
LIKE WHY DON'T WANT ANY OF US
THEN YOU KNOW IF IF YOU'RE GONNA
TALK LIKE THAT WILL WE DON'T
pOPPOSE EVERY. DRIVERLESS
VEHICLE
BILL.
WHICH I HAVE AND AND YOU KNOW I
MEAN IT YOU KNOW JUST ON AND ON
THE FACT THAT THESE ARE JOB
KILLERS.
THAT'S NOT PRODUCTIVE AT THEIR
AND I'M I'M VERY WELL AWARE OF
THAT BUT I THINK HAPPEN AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S RIGHT LIKE.
MAYBE MAYBE WE'VE GONE ABOUT
THIS WRONG AND MAYBE THE RIGHT
WAY IS AND HOW THESE PUBLIC
HEARINGS MAYBE IT IS.
REALLY WITH SOME PRESSURE
HAVING SOME VERY REALISTIC
DISCUSSIONS.
WITH EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE TO
SAY YOU KNOW.
IT'S NOT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE PRE INDUSTRIAL SOCIETY. OR
OR THAT THE INDUSTRIAL AGE AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO.
ROBOTIC GAUGE SO SO HOW DO WE.
.
HOW DO WE WORK TOGETHER IN IN
FACT THE TRAINING STUFF IN
PARTICULAR I THINK I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST WORKFORCE TRAINING I'M FOR
THE EXISTING WORK FORCE THAT WE
CAN KIND OF? WAIT OUT THE TIME I
THINK ON ON ON SOME FOLKS THE
WORKFORCE BUT OUR NEXT
GENERATION LIKE YOU SAID OF KIDS
THEY'RE NOT BEING TRAINED FOR
THESE JOBS EITHER AND THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC I MEAN THE FACT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE. WE HAVE AN
EXTENDED THE THE SUCCESS OF THE.
NEW BUILDING TRADES
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM INTO
OTHER SECTORS I'M IN A LOT OF
OTHER OUNTRIES HE'S HOUSE THEY
FIGURED THAT OUT SO HOW HOW DO
WE.
YOU KNOW IN AND KIND OF I THINK
BACK EVEN WHAT WE DON'T SEE T..
AND GENERAL YOU KNOW WOULD I
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL THERE'S TO
AUTOMOTIVE SHOP YOU KNOW NOW WE
DON'T HAVE THAT YET WE HAVE A
WHOLE NEW LINE OF AUTOMOBILES.
THAT WILL STILL NEED SERVICE
SEEN BY PEOPLE EVEN IF THEY'RE
RUNNING A COMPUTER TO SERVICE
THE CAR AND LIKE WHERE ARE WE
GETTING PEOPLE.
TRAINED UP TO DO THATTYPE OF
WORK IN SOUTH.
I THINK THOSE ARE THE KIND OF.
EASIER SOFTER DISCUSSIONS YOU
KNOW THE BORDER OF THE PUZZLE
THAT WE COULD PUT TOGETHER
EASIER ON THAT ALLOW US TO GET
TO THOSE REALLY TOUGH. ALL BLUE
SKY THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE PIECES MATCH.
SO I LOVE THAT ANALOGY BECAUSE
I THINK.
WERE NOT EVEN DOING A VERY GOOD
JOB OF HAVING THAT DISCUSSION.
RIGHT.
AND FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
VERY.
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH ALL THE
PARTIES AND STAKEHOLDERS THAT
YOU HEARD FROM TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING US YET.
ABOUT PUBLIC COMMENT AS ANYONE
WISHING TO GET PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE HAVE A MICROPHONE HERE TO MY
LEFT IF YOU WOULD COME FORWARD.
AND GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
HI. MY NAME IS MARK MORRIS I'M
WITH THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF AMERICAN BEEN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FOR FORTY ONE
YEARS. THE COMMUNICATION CLOUD
IS NOT A NATURALLY OCCURRING
PHENOMENON OR IN INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILT BY THE INVISIBLE HAND OF
THE MARKET.
IT IS BUILT AND MAINTAINED BY
TRAIN DEDICATED MEMBERS OF CW
WAY AND THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS
BEING THE COLLECTED BY
CORPORATIONS IN PURSUIT OF
PROFIT. ALL OF THIS WHETHER IT'S
ROBOT TO ROBOT HUMAN TO ROLL BUT
THIS COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURES DEPENDENT WHAT
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA ARE DOING NOW. AND AVE
DONE IN THE LAST TWO DECADES
THAT IT I FIND IT TROUBLING THAT
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA IS NOT INCLUDED IN THIS
DISCUSSION. BECAUSE WITHOUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE NONE OF THIS WILL
BE HAPPENING RIGHT AT THIS VERY
MOMENT THERE ARE OF THEM.
MEMBERS AND OF THE ENGINEERS
TECHNICIANS A WORKERS AND
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS AND
VERGE IN VIRGINIA AND WEST
VIRGINIA THAT HAVE BEEN OUT OF
WORK FOR A WEEK ON STRIKE.
BECAUSE THE THE COMPANY OF
FRONTIER FEELS THAT ALL OF THIS
MAGIC CAN HAPPEN WITHOUT HUMAN
BEINGS AND IT'S NOT TRUE WE ARE
DEBT WE ARE TOO LITERALLY IN THE
TRENCHES EXTREMELY.
A YOU YOU EXPRESS WHY YOU
WEREN'T HERE TODAY THAT'S AN
OVERSIGHT I'LL TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT I THANK
YOU I'M GONNA ASK MY STAFF TO
CONNECT WITH YOU ARE LABOR STATS
CONNECT WITH YOU. ON THIS IS NOT
THE LAST CONVERSATION WITH THE
FIRST OF MANY AND WE HOPE TO BE
A PART OF IT.
OKAY TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SARAH
FLOCKS IN THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION I JUST REALLY WANTED
TO THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT HEARING.
WE HAVE OUR HAD OUR LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES YESTERDAY AND WE HAVE OUR
LOBBY DO TODAY WE HAD WO
SESSIONS ON THE FUTURE OF WORK
AND TECHNOLOGY AND AUTOMATION
THE IMPACT ON THE THOUGH
WORKPLACE. YESTERDAY AND.
PRETTY MUCH EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO ATTENDED. EVERY YOU KNOW
MEMBER WHO ATTENDED THOSE
SESSIONS HAD A STORY ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY HOW TECHNOLOGY HAD
CHANGED HER IMPACT.
IMPACTED THEIR WORKPLACE WHAT IT
WAS NURSES ACTORS OF THAT.
YOU KNOW WORKERS AT PGA AN E.
IBEW BUILDING TRADES. ACROSS THE
BOARD I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
REALLY SEEN AN ISSUE THAT HAS
TOUCHED SO MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
LIVES. AS TECHNOLOGY AND IT WAS
NOT JUST.
WE'RE AFRAID OF THE ROBOT
APOCALYPSE THERE WAS YOUR PEOPLE
WHO HAD COME UP THROUGH THE FILM
INDUSTRY WHO HAD BEEN FILM
EDITORS WHEN THERE WAS FILM.
WHO HAD ADAPTED TO THE CHANGES
TO DIGITAL SO THEIR WISDOM
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF CREATIVITY IN
THAT ROOM AND SOME GREAT IDEAS?
SO WE WERE VERY INSPIRED
ENCOURAGE I THINK THIS IS
PERFECT TIMING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M DRILL COOK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION UP FIRST
AGAIN WANT TO THANK BOTH OF THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEES WERE HAVING THIS.
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY IT'S ONE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US IS
MANUFACTURES WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH THIS ISSUE OF AUTOMATION
AND LABOR FOR ABOUT TWENTY TO
THIRTY YEARS NOW IN EARNEST.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS A TRANSITION OF A TO A
LABOR FORCE THAT IS A MORE
HYBRIDIZED WHERE WE HAVE WORKERS
AND OUT ROBOTS WORKING TOGETHER
BUT WE SEE OUR OUR OUR. HUMAN
LABOR MOVING UPSTREAM TO HIGHER
SKILLED A HIGHER VALUE TO MORE
COMPLEX WORK.
ARE.
THE ISSUES THAT WE FACE THE MORE
WE NEED HELP IS DEALING WITH OUR
OUR OUR PIPELINE PROGRAMS WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH.
.
PEOPLE COMING THROUGH THE
PIPELINE BETTER EQUIPPED WITH
THE TECHNICAL SKILLS OUGHT TO
JUMP INTO THESE MORE ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING PROGRAMS BUT WE
ALSO ARE LOOKING FOR MORE
PROGRAMS THAT. ARE CAN ASSIST US
IN RETRAINING AND UPSCALING
WORKERS AYE SO THAT THEY CAN FOR
PHIL.
THESE RULES THAT WE HAVE BETTER
JOBS THAT ARE FAR HIGHER SKILLED
HIGHLY PAID AND HIGHLY STABLE. A
AND AN ADDITIONAL TENSION.
AS DID IN ADDITION TO ONES THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN
MENTIONED EARLIER IS THAT
AUTOMATION FOR MANUFACTURERS IS
CRITICAL TO ALSO HITTING THE THE
GOALS THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
SET. IN REGARDS TO UGH CLEANER A
GREENER JOBS HITTING OUR ENERGY
ADMIT THAT OUR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
GOALS WELLS ARE ODD GREENHOUSE
GAS AND EMISSIONS GOALS FOR ALL
OF THESE. ARE.
COME FOOT BEING COMPETING
INTERESTS HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER
OUT TO SUPPORT OUR ECONOMY MAKE
CALIFORNIA GREATER SO AQ HOPING
TO WORK WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE
ON THIS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RENEWING MY NAME
STAND SOUTH OF SOME WITH
COMMUNICATION WORKERS ALSO BUT
I'M SPEAKING AS A A. SPLICING
TECHNICIAN.
MYSELF I'M A CONSTRUCTION
SPLICER AND I HAVE A A BROTHER
WHO'S A MAINTENANCE PLACER. AND
OUR EXPERIENCE ALTHOUGH THE
WHITE PICTURE ON TECHNOLOGY AND
HOW IT'S DISPLACED ARE ABOUT
WORKERS SINCE BEEN REALLY.
A TRAGEDY. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AUTOMATED PROMPTS THE OFF
SHORING AND OUR CLOSURE OF CALL
CENTERS.
AND THAT'S IMPACT THE CALIFORNIA
TREMENDOUSLY THEY MOVE HIM.
SNOW EAST AND THEN THEY MOVE
THEM OVERSEAS AND AT SOME OF IT
SO MUCH OF ITS AUTOMATED THAT
IT'S REALLY A. AFFECTING OUR.
CUSTOMERS THE OTHER PART IS THE
NEW SYSTEMS THAT THE COMING IN.
THE WIRELESS HOME PHONE. A A LOT
OF THE WIRELESS PRODUCTS WE
STILL WORK ON CABLE COPPER AND
OPTICAL FIBER MYSELF I SPICE
AND.
NO WORKING BOTH.
WHAT I'VE DISCOVERED IS THAT
THOSE SYSTEMS THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO BRING IN AND OVERLY
WHICH A WIRELESS?
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
WHICH LED TO THE TRAGEDY THAT
HAPPENED WHICH CLAIMED OR FORTY
LIVES IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE EFFECTS OF THESE FIRES AND
NATURAL AND MAN MADE DISASTERS
WILLING TO SEE THAT INCREASE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE NOT
GIVEN THE CAPACITY THE ABILITY
TO REALLY MAINTAIN THOSE
NETWORKS. ANOTHER MOVING TO A
WIRELESS PLATFORM WHERE I'VE
SEEN AND IF YOU GO BACK IN TIME
TO FUKUSHIMA. YOU GO TO A
HURRICANE AS SANDY IN THE EAST
COAST AND YOU SEE PEOPLE LINING
UP. AT PAY PHONES.
BECAUSE THEIR WIRELESS TOWERS
WENT DOWN IN SOME CASES IT'S THE
TELEPHONE POLES THAT BURN THEN
THERE'S NO COPPER CONNECTIVITY.
MY POINT IS THIS THAT A LOT OF
THESE CORPORATIONS.
ARE PUTTING ALL THEIR MONEY INTO
THIS PRUDENT PERSON AT THE FIRST
RESPONDER NETWORK THE EMERGENCY
NETWORK.
WELL THERE'S THIS THING CALLED
A.
I GUESS IT'S PREEMPTION BUT IT'S
ALSO CALLED ANOTHER TERM FOR IT
IS BRUTAL PREEMPTION I THINK
IT'S CALLED. ANYWAY IT'S THE ONE
WHERE THEY. USE THE NETWORK THEY
TAKE OVER THE NETWORK AND THEN.
ONLY FIRST RESPONDED TRAFFIC
IT'S ALLOWED ON IT.
AND LOT OF OUR CUSTOMERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO REACH OUT TO THE LOVE
ONES AREN'T ABLE TO. AND THE
FACT IS THE NETWORK DOESN'T EVEN
HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR THEM WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WE THINK
THAT THEY'RE NOT PUTTING ENOUGH
INVESTMENT CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
THEY NO LONGER OPERATING
REDUNDANT I MEAN.
WHO WHAT I GUESS YOU'D CALL
READINGS WHERE YOU HAVE POINT
NAY WHERE THE COMMUNITY IS AND
POINT B. WHICH IS THE WORLDWIDE
NETWORK?
THEY'RE ALL IN ONE CABLE AND A
FARMER IS DIGGING A DITCH YOUR
DIGGING A TELEPHONE POLE IN HIS.
NORTH FORTY AND HE HITS ONE OF
OUR CABLES ANY KNOCKS DOWN TWO
OR THREE OF OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE I COME FROM
ANY KNOCKS DOWN A COUPLE OF.
CELL TOWERS
SO THAT'S A CONCERN OF A RURAL
COMMUNITIES WE'D LIKE YOU TO
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT IS
AUTOMATION GOES FOR TECHNOLOGY
GOES FORWARD. WITH THE ONES THAT
ARE OUT THERE AND WE CARE ABOUT
OUR CUSTOMERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. POWER THANK EVERYONE
WHO GAVE UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
I DON'T THINK THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THE STAFF OF BOTH COMMITTEES
AND UP ALL THE PANELISTS
UNKNOWNS ALSO THINK CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION THE TEAMSTERS.
SUPPORTED DEVELOPING THE AGENDA
FOR TODAY BUT CLEARLY WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. AND LET THIS
BE THE FIRST OF MANY
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE DO
TOGETHER.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR INTEREST IN THE SUBJECT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR NEXT
STEPS BUT AS OF NOW THIS HEARING
IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU